ming avec notre événement du tata steel
et on arrive à la ronde 8 ça a déjà bien
avancé avec un magnus carlsen de gala
qui est en tête stouff
y est allé kevin salut à tous donc on a
des appartements de luxe aujourd'hui
avec jean claude carle scène américaine
c'est
exact donc on va voir si je pense va
essayer de mettre la pression sur
changement dans cette partie ouais parce
que vraiment je n'ai pas besoin qu'il
est blanc il essaie un se trouve pour
l'instant magnus puis est vraiment la
première ronde contre contes récits
penguin et encore je crois qu'il a
essayé mais si bien qu il avait essayé
de le bloquer magnus a une petite chance
là avec ses pions pendant mais sinon il
vraiment ils jouent toutes ces parties
c'est vraiment agréable à suivre un noir
blanc il s'en fout et jouer si l'autre
si l'on ne mérite ça nul ils annulent
sinon signe le bakoye grosse mentalité
gros guerrier
va vraiment vraiment en tout cas ça va
être intéressant assure donc deuxième
chez qui on a on a un choc
as tu nous le devons bien stouff
tu ne le vois bien
la maison blanche
vous l'avez vu arriver cette histoire de
poulain il ya toujours ça entre nous
avec stouff on parie des petits seul et
puis après on aime bien vous vendre nos
poulains vous savez comment ça se passe
un peu de mauvaise foi n'a jamais tué
personne et en même temps nos poulains
ils sont hyper forte puisque c'est un
des tournois les plus forts au monde que
l'on suit donc on a beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de chance de commenter ce
tournoi pour de chasse comme avec avec
souffre
du coup m'hammed grine ananda ça peut
feuilleter c'est ce que tout fait en
train de nous annoncer et je suis
complètement d'accord a réduit la comme
l'autre ils font des parties de folie
bats chaque jour on a vu prat contre car
le seigneur il a est pas une a perdu
mais il a il a fait il a fait vraiment
une partie où il avait envie d'envoyer
mamediarov s'anime contre rapporte
c'était une nulle de gros combattants
et
à cinq points sur sept suivi de près par
mamediarov quatre et demi donc ouverte
avec les blancs on va essayer de tirer
ça tirait son gain pour rattraper car
c'est toi tu m'as réfuté une expression
tirée s'annulent tu m'as fait tirer son
gain c'est ce que je la retire celle là
je la retiens pas mal celle
normalement l'autre commentateurs qui
est sympa et bienveillant et normand il
fait pas remonter ce genre d'info à tout
le monde tu vois mais bon tu sais bien
comment le fils j'ai pas pu m'empêcher
souffre je suis désolé je suis désolé et
pas tant que ça en même temps c'est bien
tu meures voudra satwa sens où je sais
que je me rends compte que des fois je
divague je divague
car yakine rapporte ça m'intéresse
est-ce que cariat keane va réussir à
visser rapporte parce que car yakine un
bon style quand même pour battre importe
avec une grosse prépare qu'un peu un peu
pénible comme il a comme il a battu vont
de faurecia de rondo 6 avait été la
masterclass il a souligné hier
est-ce qui peut faire plus la même chose
ça lui convient
d'accord
je vois bien car yakine s'il est motivé
faire un pressing mais on verra bien
autres matches aussi entre visites et
news grande des lieux vraiment
aujourd'hui à part dans le match numéro
un
shankland 40 scène on a bien envie de
prendre les blancs parce qu'on voit
quand même que les favoris dans chaque
match a son plutôt les blancs ce que vit
dit grande des lieux en visite hier et
il a subi la loi
l'assaut de la loi d'un certain
d'un certain vent de forest mai
c'est vrai qu'il est plutôt en forme
dans ce dans ce tournoi donc grand des
lieux souffre pas mal il est noir quant
à lui s'il a un style sans concession
née en moi
je vois bien je vois bien vidé de devant
après avoir un avoir
pareil tu vois caruana pouy deschamps
prix excuse moi souffle
grande et les os il adore la baston ce
qui est super mais on voit qu'à ce
niveau là ma l'ensemble des joueurs ils
ont plutôt un style pour pousser avec le
petit plus et lui on voit que sont un
peu l'épreuve du feu quand il arrive à
ce niveau là proche des 27
c'est quand même hyper dur pour lui pour
l'instant ils n'arrivent pas encore à
passer ce cap
bon on verra pas ce que ce style sans
concession ça peut ça peut lui amener
des victoires éclatantes mais pour
l'instant saint paul à la souffrance
et du coup on en profite pour dire salut
à tous ceux qui nous ont rejoints
salut à toi lui you qui me disait un
petit bonjour
robin sage et replacer la victoire
devant de forest c'est un des éléments
marquants en fait un comme celle de
magnus contre prague tu vois un vraiment
je rappelle toutes les victoires c'est
pas pour replacer mon poulain et
dénigrer le poulain ne souffre pas du
tout c'est juste que c'est les éléments
marquants de la journée d'hier quoi
voilà faut savoir être honnête quand
camps commente un sou c'est ça je crois
le note notre mot d'ordre
allez je peux je peux vous faire des
folies bats toi je l'avais mis très fort
hier pour vraiment contente bien
est ce que tu veux que je baisse aussi
ton micro moi j'ai pas touché aux miens
mais il est peut-être déjà fort
d'origine et le tient je l'avais dit
ouais mais toi je voulais vraiment de
voir dans le rouge stouff
je voulais entendre que tu écris tu
écris
alors je peux faire ça
je suis de m
ghazi voilà tu t'es mieux tu étais en
t1b jaune et du coup moi je vais mettre
un petit peu moins fort que c'est
surtout stouff d'entrée tu me dit kevin
mieux toi un petit peu pas complètement
mais mais moi un petit peu j'ai pas
envie que je tente chanter toute la
journée avec vente fort reste
et du coup je vais m'exécuter hop et du
coup tac voilà je devrais être un petit
peu mieux mais bon en tant qu'homme
malgré tout malgré ce petit cette petite
modification quand même pas mal je pense
pop
aux
[Musique]
nettement caruana et pas forcément hyper
en forme dans son âme et maintenant qui
viendra collet a dude ah ben ça va il ya
il est à niveau caruana pièces blanches
qu'on ne vende forest
malgré que von euw forêt soit mon
poulain le choix de la raison m'oblige
à dire que caruana est favori ce qui met
vente forest en gros outsider et ça
serait un authentique exploit qui
viennent à gagner aujourd'hui non mais
je crois que caruana est vraiment pour
moi caruana c'est actuellement
moi ça ça n'engage que moi le le
challenger de magnus quoi pour moi c'est
le candidat le plus sérieux
au titre au titre mondial mais bon il
faut passer les candidats elle est
candidat il yad'autres extrême bons
joueurs du coup c'est pas c'est pas
fasse pas si facile et j'en ai bien
conscience
non mais complètement complètement l'ail
est en train de se refaire s il veut
jouer pour quelque chose ce tournoi il
est obligé de gagner aujourd'hui avec
les pièces blanches
et on a le retour stouff de 2 du beauf
contre eux duda qui a perdu hier
justement contre caruana qu'est ce que
tu penses de ce match un peu bizarre
parce que vous avez que du mof il a fait
forfait hier pour des raisons de cas
contacts qu vide qu'est ce que tu penses
de tout cela souffle
tout fait ce que tu mende est ce que tu
pensais d'eux nous bouddha est en fait
il y ait eu une petite cerise
ouais ça ça serait pas si étonnant
oui avec un doux doit pas très en forme
du bois enfin les deux viennent de
perdre si on considère que du bois a
perdu quand même c'est par forfait c'est
comme ça et si penco contre eux jiri
cipango qui montre une belle forme dans
ce tournoi giri qui est en train de
revenir à la surprise générale
gaffe plus forfait à ce niveau là c'est
vraiment assez incroyable donc ça promet
jiri pièce pièce noire et si penco
plutôt en forme franchement ça va être
une belle journée niveau et chic
oui c'est un petit peu excitant pour
nous directement et on va on va aller
voir on va les voir cette partie avec
champions qui est déjà en réflexion
parce que magnus il a déjà balancé un
pion en fait stouff avec l'avant de
tarage du grand midam
du coup on va vous montrer un petit peu
on va vous montrer un petit peu comment
ça s'est passé c'est vrai que ça
m'arrive de jouer des ventes comme ça
sur internet joue pas mal le grand midam
donc là aussi ce grand vide à me refuser
on s'attend à une partie un peu plate
plate et sur cavaliers c3
c5 met le feu aux poudres puisque vous
savez dans la gambie d'âme quand je
cassais trois ans développe à plus les
pièces de l'ale dame ce qui fait qu'on
retarde notre petit rock et en jouant
ses cinq mâles et noir font quelque
chose d'assez logique il met
le feu au centre maintenant c'est pas
une ouverture hyper est utilisé par ce
que il ya un problème en mettant le feu
au centre ce qu'il faut pas oublier
c'est qu'il ya un petit problème il ya
c'est prendre et 5 et à terme si les
noirs viennent à faire reprendre les
saints qui vont se retrouve avec un peu
isolé presque perdu avec les les ventes
des français 5 1 souffre du coup on peut
vite avoir des petits soucis
dont il ya eu c'est prendre
avec
l'idée sans doute que sur dame prend des
cats on peut faire des choses avec avec
cavaliers c6 ya des choses comme ça et
du coup pour éviter ce schéma ben
champion bat des cils jeu damas quatre
carlos n avait sans doute prévu déjà là
moi je suis je suis en théorie souffre à
sa promesse d'un macaque fou 17 on
provoque le courroux des sept
d'en prendre quatre et là peut prendre
et 5 qu'est ce qui s'est passé on voit
que donc champion n'a pas vraiment
respecté les principes qu'il a sa date
de sortie mais en fait il va gagner un
pion donc c'est vraiment une position de
gambie avec les noirs puisque les
champions dont il a pris le pion plus
assez logique qu'il évite ce cavalier c6
par la même occasion mais magnus propose
et c'est un cas classique quand sa fille
un premier pion il vous en propose un
deuxième pour avoir une maxi avance de
développement avec les noirs c'est
souvent ce que je dis souvent c'est que
les gambier avec baignoire normalement
c'était extrêmement douteux et on voit
que quinzaine c'est parti il montre
qu'il a envie de gagner avec des noirs
avec ce choix d'ouverture je dirais pas
risqué mais ambitieux
ouais
c'est vous
celles ci sont six touches qui doit être
sympa je viens d'y penser jamais penser
comme toi faisait 6 au premier abord et
là je viens de me dire tiens cavaliers
ces six ont été sympas aussi avec la
menace cali et bekaert et qui a aidé 4
je sais pas si c'est pas encore mieux
vous voyez qu'il a essayé six il ya deux
menaces il faut pas que je me fasse
contre 1 qui a aimé 5,1 g pas tout
calculer mais il ya dans la foulée cadre
d'un mac adam à 5
fu bécade surtout vous voyez ça c'est
rigolo si alors je sais pas avec avec
stouff comme comme on jouerait
véritablement si d'emprunt bessette bain
et jouée par par shankland mais on peut
douter que magnus lui le sait voilà en
tout cas je crois très très ambitieux et
et c'est dur pour shankland dans cette
position s'il ne la connais pas ce qui
est peut-être pas impossible je sais pas
ce que dit la base de données vous savez
on travaille sans module sans base de
données c'est plus sympa comme ça alors
moi j'adore savoir ce que dit la théorie
mais en tout cas si shankland il n'a pas
bien bossé cette position il peut pas
les gober bessette et là je peux vous
dire il a joué dame b 3 dans la partie
est du coup du coup c'est le choix de la
raison il va essayer de bétonner cette
position
j'ai joué il n'y a pas si longtemps
contraint m ce type de position avec le
vague l'option de plus mais ce n'était
pas exactement cette
version c'était bien une tare h
et du coup j'avais réussi à gagner la
partie mais en 81 coups avec le pion de
plus et honnêtement c'était nul donc ce
qui se passe comme à chaque fois c'est
que magnus je vais avoir une forte
activité de pièces et ça me chante
landes un pion à valoriser plus tard
mais avant de valoriser ce non plus il
va se prendre une grosse pression de la
part de magnus c'est certain en tout cas
ça me donne envie de bosser un petit peu
ce genre de variantes pour plus tard a
titre perso pour avoir du jeu avec avec
les noirs sur des cats souffler parce
que tu en penses quoi toi ça de votre
père aussi un toit qui est un gros
joueur d'attac c'est assez plaisant de
d'entamer le combat avec baignoire comme
çà sur des cartes quoi puisque dans
l'autre des quatre c'est plus plat plus
stratégique
en plus lentement il est hyper il est
hyper hyper solide et juhasz et
professionnels donc je pense que c'est
intéressant de
[Musique]
voir
en tout cas c'est hyper ambitieux c'est
comme ça
c'est top pour le spectacle c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment très très bien
on vient parce que des fois il ya des
partis un peu enlevée comme ça qu'ils
qui finit sur des choses un peu modeste
mais
c'est sûr que c'est c'est vraiment sympa
voilà
des gambie des gambie
on a un petit souci pour entendre
correctement stouff
ok il ya cinq ans j'étais bien là en
tant mieux l'entente en mieux
effectivement souffre
plus tes proches
de l'ordi ou du micro je sais pas mieux
je t'entends rating perso après ça doit
être relayée dans dans comment dirais-je
dans le stream on va voir en tout cas
moi je reste je pense que je reste fort
et toi on verra bien je trouve quand tu
vas quoi ouais ouais c'était mieux
néandertal nous dit que c'est beaucoup
mieux merci à toi néandertal pour pour
l'aide technique
tu sais que j'aime les aides techniques
à
voilà ben franchement bon moment d'être
paraissait bla pour le début on va aller
tourner un petit peu ce touché parce que
tu en penses mais cette partie
m'intéresse au plus haut point j'arrive
vérifier la théorie parce que j'ai joué
un joueur français claude adrian ya pas
si longtemps sur ce genre de position et
mais ce n'était pas exactement je ferai
ça ma pause gérer vérifier un petit peu
je serai vérifier pour une fois un petit
chèque on change est ce qu'on va voir
mamediarov roi gyanendra qu'une des
parties qui promet le plus aujourd'hui
hier ça devrait aller voir quand j'ai vu
l'ouverture et damas car c'est
intéressant
ouais donc c'est une variante assez
connue contre contre l'anglais il me
semble que tu joues ça non sous ces
bosses toi qui a dit ça
ouais ouais c'est ça avec plusieurs
plusieurs choix
j'ai obligé oublié le nom de ta
variantes en fait c'est quoi ces avant
de caresser chez les plus jeunes ouais
mais pourtant elle a un nom mais bon
c'est alors dans le tchat aidez-nous un
lacet une vente de l'anglais sont
pourtant assez connu un système karpov
avec fous ces cinq très connu on va dire
systèmes ouverts à l'envers avec la f6
des sacs et et là j'ai croqué le nom
mais en tout cas ok des cats et le coup
vraiment logique sur ces 6 on avait vu
des choses comme ça déjà souffre parce
qu'on se croise et prend des daims prend
dé la dame viendrait au centre sans
pouvoir se faire chasser par cavalier c6
et du coup on après sur le pion 17 donc
les noirs ont préféré jouer avec eux
quatre
lucky normal
et là il ya un coût très très étonnant
de la part de m'améliorer off qui est
forcément préparé je suis pas sûr que ce
soit théorique même si enfin ça doit pas
de la côte est de la grande variante
sauvette une souris j'imagine bien sûr
macabre j'espère que tout le monde
comprend pas ce que c'est très
intéressant on ainsi sur sa dans nos
commentaires sur le jeu avec les pions
parce que pour les joueurs amateurs on
sait que c'est difficile et regarder de
damas carte à quel point c'est
intelligent parce que c'est un coup anti
conditionnelle on sort la dame dès le
début mais c'est pour interdire des 5
quand vous allez me dire oui c'est
possible mais sur ces prend des on ne
peut plus reprendre du pied on sait ce
qui est l'idée dans ses positions de
base pour conserver le centre donc là
c'est un coup hyper intelligent et si je
vous dis que c'est un possible
simplement c'est parce que madame se
retrouve en vis-à-vis du rouen 8 je
pense que ça se comprend assez
facilement et on interdit la
reconstruction central des noirs et du
cou
on veut à terme taper sur ce pion le 4
et il y aura plusieurs schémas donc
l'attaquer directement par cas et ses
trois fous j'ai 2 et souffre on voit
aussi des f3 pour pour tout péter au
centre si vraiment les noirs et
s'accrocher à leurs pions
ok
mais en tout cas des cinq a été joué et
vous voyez je pense que prague il a été
un petit peu surpris souffre puisque il
a passé quand même une dizaine de
minutes sur wade a passé 11 minutes pour
trouver des cinq ici va trouver pour
valider le choix de faire des 5es et
m'hamed il a pris un tempo
donc c'est c'est sa préparation cette
histoire de base y joue moi des cinq
hockey et pour pouvoir reprendre du pied
il ya tout un combat qui est en train de
se créer pour pouvoir reprendre du pian
prague il vient de faire des 5 enfin le
dire ça une forme de logique oui mais
c'est comme un affaiblissement et on
peut imaginer peut-être d'un bep trois
souffre de la part de m'hamed pour
forcer ou non parce que peut-être que ça
s'est jamais en tout cas vous voyez pour
garder une pression sur b5 et pour
forcer plutôt dans prend alors peut-être
que prague sur dame et 3 va prendre du
plomb et un peu comme magnus le fait
dans sa partie met dans une position
très différente il pourrait on pourrait
imaginer le sacrifice du pion b5 on va
mais sur deux dans le premier cinq
échecs c'est un petit peu énervant quand
même regarder ce que je vois d'un bep
trois pions prend des cinq pour essayer
d'un premier 5 et là j'ai un problème
parce que si je vous fous 17 ou
cavaliers 17 bayas option là qui saute
et c'est quand même un pion important
donc
du coup on peut imaginer que sur dame b
3 les noirs prennent plutôt de leurs
dames avec leurs dames
et là j'ai plusieurs coups candidat j'ai
cavaliers c3 qui est pour moi un coup
candidats world ham d1 mais c'est
qu'elle sait trois que je regarde en
premier pour mettre une pression sur la
position adverse
hyper compliqué dès le début franchement
c'est un peu galère pour
reprendre nalanda s'il est vraiment pas
en courant dans cette position
sauf considère 11 minutes c'est
peut-être pour se rappeler mais que
c'est pas non plus 30 minutes ça que tu
veux dire souvent
mais il est
mais
tu nous parler des bluffs dans les
ouvertures et peut-être que la prépa ce
matin tu lui a conseillé de faire ta
technique du bluff on a eu de gros
anecdotes les règles stouff et du coup
peut-être que son poulain ma il choisit
la la la même astuce que stouff avec un
petit boeuf au début pour jouer des 5 et
après dès qu'il ya eu prise il envoie il
envoie tout de la prépa en fait créé pas
caché peut-être de prés de landas non je
ne sais pas qui ça en rigolant mais non
je pense que il a cherché à se rappeler
il a retrouvé relativement vite onze
minutes on rappelle normalement on passe
pas plus de façons de 20-30 minutes
vraiment c'est le max du max sur un même
et unique coup sinon ça veut dire que ça
va pas
en règle générale il ya des
contre-exemples mais une partie déjà
assez assez créa dès le début ce qui
n'est pas étonnant de la part d'un
milliard off qui par exemple il ya une
partie assez mémorable dans son moi
c'est contré si bien qu il a très vite
au troisième coup
ou c'est le quatrième enfin peu importe
jouer quelque chose qui ne se fait pas
du tout avec un gros g4 dans la nuit zoo
c'était au troisième d'ailleurs des 4 4
6 et 4 6 g 4 c'était du grand délire et
finalement la partie avait fait une
belle nul de combat on reste un peu sur
notre faim les deux joueurs s'étaient
fait peur voilà ce qu'on peut dire de
cette partie
on reste sur selah sue faux est ce que
tu veux aller
allez un autre endroit on peut aller
alors vers quoi tu veux qu'on se dirige
alors mamediarov fera une annonce si
ping calls nana na na na na je crois
qu'on peut aller voir peut-être
caruana vent de forest tu vois pourquoi
je dis ça on a été voir le plein de
stuff pourquoi on n'irait pas voir
mon petit poulain et je vais vous mettre
la cam parce que je vous ai laissé
champion de 400 ch et bien que vous avez
bien regardé car en scène puis des fois
pour tout vous avouer je me doubliez un
petit peu changer de caméra dans ce cas
la faune le fond me le rappeler dans le
chat se soucie et voilà voilà voilà
ouais c'est j'en sais c'est bien gentil
ça lui arrache salue tous ceux qui nous
rejoignent dans le chat et une partie
déjà très avancé souffre avec un
déséquilibre majeur matériel et je dois
avouer je connais assez peu sujet tu va
peut-être pouvoir nous éclairer stouff
chez que j'ai regardé il ya très très
longtemps c'est tout ce qu'on appelle
les espagnols ouverte
est à spécialité parce que je sais que
c'est plutôt les joueurs positionnelle
et du coup est ce que tu peux nous en
dire plus c'est ce que tu es spécialisé
là dedans puisque moi c'est hors de mon
champ de compétence pourtant je dis que
j'ai une connaissance assez large la
théorie mais là tu vois je suis coincé
j'ai finalement menti et je te laisse
avec la patate chaude ou pas à toi de me
dire sauf si tu connais bien ce genre de
position d'espagnol classique au début
est ouverte parce que cavalier f6 petit
rock plutôt que de jouer les espagnols
fermés avec b5 fawcett qu'on a beaucoup
vu dans les matchs de championnat du
monde entre carlson et pau
ou entre néo peau et 15 scène puisque
c'est nepomniachi qu'il y avait les
blancs mais là avec les noirs quand ça
ne faisait jamais cavalier prochain 4
qui est la prépa visiblement de jordan
vente forest des cas que c'est normal ça
ressemble un petit peu aux
compositions de mur de berlin sauf que
pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas sauf
qu'il ya eu à 6 et fo à 4 d'intercaler
donc dans cette position
après des quatre il ya une baie 5 qui
est permis dans ce genre de position et
surtout b3 la grande théorie pour calmer
les ardeurs des blancs puisque là il ya
déjà des problèmes quand même attention
fou des cinq attention tour eu un break
et le roi qui clignote un peu rouge pour
calmer tout ça on sécurise la position
avec des 5
tout simplement pour casser la diagonale
du fou mais 3 et sur des preuves fou
aussi cela on est devant de la grande
théorie voilà donc c'est la théorie pure
de l'espagnol ouverte aux quais et sur
ses trois fils est sain que toi tu
connais bien ses fans ce genre de
position parce que moi en fait nous
malheureusement ouais
c'est quand même plutôt les joueurs pour
ça
il ya une partie comme ça dans le
tournoi avec
c'est quand même du grand classique à
haut niveau mais à niveau franchement
jusqu'à 2500 n'en vois pas énormément
des ehpad des espagnols ouverte par
rapport aux espagnols dit fermer quoi
les espagnols complètement classique et
du coup c'est assez intéressant et là je
peux pas te dire souffre c'est pour ça
que j'attende
j'attends de toit des réponses souffle
puisque surqualifiés rock attendais pas
tu vois un peu la problématique c'est
fou ces deux cavaliers pros f2 et ben
ouais c'est pas évident pour nous parce
que normalement c'est un sacrifice assez
des conseillers alors on comprend qu'il
y a une petite astuce derrière c'est à
dire qu'on donne pas dans deux pièces
magistrales contre la pauvre tour f1
alors même si un pion donc il ya un
certain équilibre matériel quoiqu un fou
ces trois et demi et le à regarder il ya
le clouage bateau on n'est pas obligé de
prendre la tour directement et ven de
forrest a joué ça je pense pour
affaiblir le roi blanc est directement
il joue f6 il est sans doute encore dans
une prépa souffre même peut-être dans la
grande ligne théorique je sais pas si tu
as les éléments devant toi je vous
rappelle qu'en ont fait les commentaires
sans module et sans s en base de données
sauf si on va chercher les infos mais là
ce n'est pas le cas donc cavalier f1 et
maintenant il a appris à f2 regardez ce
que ça change d'un roi prend puis on
prend 1,5 et il ya une grande colonne
ouverte sur le roi un gros centre
possibilité de faire quatre donc
légitimement caruana qui connaît sans
doute cette position a je crois j'ai un
roi g1 pour se remettre dans son dans sa
petite cabane habituel avec le petit
rock peut-être un jour où agen pour
vraiment sécurisé tout ça et d'amd si ça
a été le jouet pour bien garder le
centre et on peut imaginer qu'une des
urgences ça va être dos telle autre tour
peut-être un f6 je ne sais pas mais
mettre les deux tours sur la colonne f
ou tout au moins si je ne double pas
activer cette tour en des 8 ou en 8
donc robin ça dans le chat nous dit que
mv l'année
donc ça c'est étrange parce que je vous
passe avec les noirs en tout cas parce
qu'il a dû garder la cécilienne pendant
toit du monde avec les deux relais du
jeu ça du coup les clans
ok
je n'avais jamais vu
c'est une espagnole ouverte mais je dois
je dois avouer que malheureusement pour
les commentaires je suis vraiment joueur
de sienne depuis longtemps j'ai quelques
élèves qui jouent eux 85 mais c'est vrai
que un peu par défaut est sans doute à
tort je montre les espagnols fermés
souffre
peut-être par manque de connaissances
pour une fois parce que angie non au
niveau largeur de connaissances sava 70
profondeur on n'a pas la même profondeur
tous les deux les joueurs qui sont
devant nous un forcément mais dans le
fait de commenter le fait d'être
entraîneur ça doit nous amener des
connaissances larges et je sais que j'ai
regardé ça plusieurs fois en 2015 mais
côté blanc et c'était pas c'était pas
cette ligne là ça fait déjà deux choses
à vérifier entre lattes arrache la
beaucoup de boulot et j'avoue que c'est
assez plaisant aussi de commenter je
trouve par rapport à cet aspect là
c'est la variété des débuts qui nous
sont proposées et c'est vrai que ça
m'amène à me questionner sur des débuts
où je n'ai pas l'habitude de devoir tout
fait c'est vrai que c'est plutôt rigolo
on se pose des questions sur des
structures en plus qu'on connaît pas
donc on travaille en même temps avec
souffert pendant qu'on voit là on
travaille nos échecs on va faire
d'immenses progrès normalement et
obtenir
nos titres respectifs voilà on va aller
encore plus loin souffre après dans
quelques temps grâce grâce à ces
commentaires fin j'espère en tout cas
faudrait rejouer déjà faudrait rejouer
des chevaux
mais en tout cas qu'est ce que tu penses
de cette position déséquilibrait tu
prends les blancs les noirs toi stouff
je trouve que c
[Musique]
et g calcaire pièces entre deux mais
bon dans cette position je vois un plan
j'ai envie de te le donne et enfin par
rapport à cette position je verrais bien
fouet f2 fou g3 ce que je remarque c'est
que le déséquilibre majeur de la
position c'est le fait que les blancs
ont un fou de case noire les noirs eux
ils ont le centre donc je verrai bien ce
semaine manoeuvre là qui me permettrait
de jouer sur les deux éléments et sur le
centre fort des noirs que j'ai essayé de
contrer
et sur le fait de comment fou de vienne
le plus le plus visible possible
du coup je verrais bien cette petite
manoeuvre j'aimerais bien faire bouger
le pion eux 54 parce que ça me donnerait
toutes les quinzaines war donc voilà ce
que je verrai qu'un petit banc et j'ai
aussi d'autres urgences peut-être dam
des deux tours d un c'est aussi un plan
ou tour eu un jeu c'est par mais il faut
que j'améliore sept tours 1 qui dort et
jouer sur les cases noires
j'ai du mal à cerner le plan noir en
fait
il ya peut-être l'idée toujours de fou
g4 en fait
c'est jamais possible pour l'instant il
ya fou prend achète toi qui as g5
donc j'aurai bien phu et à vous deux et
après je sais pas comment ajouté tu as
une idée stéphane pour pour la position
noir
oui c'est ça hein wyeth des quatre
ouais je mettrai mon fou en plus on
détroit pour éviter sa puis fou j'ai
trois actes mpo
j'aimerais bien fouet f2 là en tout cas
c'est le coût qui m'intéressent comme
c'est mon poulain je vais pas trop
soufflé à caruana mes idées ça
risquerait de porter préjudice aux
commandes forest donc voilà il faut pas
que j'en dise trop voilà
très très intéressant en tout cas
franchement les parties qu'on à elles
sont hyper intéressant tout ce qu'on a
vu jusqu'à présent stouff alors pourquoi
je dis intéressant parce qu'elles sont
très déséquilibrée donc vous voyez
montgallet on a besoin de prendre un
petit peu de réflexion d'ailleurs pour
réfléchir à ce qu'on ferait
ce sont pas des positions limpide qu'on
a vu plein de fois alors bien sûr on
peut trouver de régler le lit les
lettres des bases de données beaucoup
d'éléments en prenant l'historique des
parties des joueurs on n'y arrive mais
sans fil et c'est beaucoup plus
difficile et c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment assez intéressant
mais fou et f2 ça m'excite un petit peu
comme coup parce que j'adore parler le
jeu de couleurs stouff et c'est vrai que
c'est c'est pas facile fief de savoir
mais il a dû bosser de jordanie les
archis danse après la prépa c'est sûr
exact exact on continue le tour des
échiquiers
oui on y va c'est toi qui c'est toi qui
nous dit et après faudra pas qu'on
oublie notre petite frenchie marquant
dream house ziki en difficulté à vous le
savez il a un point sur sept et du coup
on espère qu'il va se refaire
et guy ici avec 1h44 il est assurément
dans sa prépa
on sait comment ça s'est passé de toute
façon ce genre de position il a balancé
sont fous ces huit conception h2g2 ça
c'est sûr on voit que c'est sans doute
une italienne allait on regarde un petit
peu comme on arrivé là stouff on sait de
toute façon
c'est du grand classique donc cavalier
f6 rapide dans l'italienne ça permet ça
laisse cavaliers gesac mais sous le plus
souvent les les joueurs décident de
jouer plutôt logique au piano c'est à
dire tranquille où on défend qu'a t on
fait une italienne classique avec plutôt
le plan qui a aidé de f1 g3 et petit
rock et tours et ses trois des quatre
finalement c'est l'italienne avec un
plan très proche de l'espagnol cette
façon je vais aux échecs on joue pour le
petit plus agréable donc poussé 5 tout
est normal pour l'instant il se passe
rien ces trois petit rock petit rock et
là une des variantes les plus
ambitieuses avec les noirs un peu dans
le style de de marshall avec avec les
sur l'espagnol puisque les pas rare de
perdre le pion aux cinq dans certaines
situations cavaliers prend est en tout
cas c'est une variante très ambitieuse
avec les noirs ou c'est vrai que mes
pièces d'apparence sont actives on a
souvent des problèmes quand je disais
avec le pion aux cinq donc tour eu un
fou j'ai quatre bons mais le fou angers
4 pour coup et le cavalier pas avoir
trop bu trop de problèmes 5 maintenant
il ya beaucoup de parties avec un g3 g4
donc on va voir comment s'est passé donc
à aimer des deux d'abord et on peut
mettre lecavalier en le cadre dans
certaines lignes
chasser avec un choix et mène le
cavalier en g3 par exemple ça se fait
aussi
pour attaquer le foie chien quel point e
5 enlever le flou âgées et cros quelques
1,5 donc à aimer si ça a été jouée avec
l'attak du fou en c4 il a choisi de pas
le défendre à 15,3
bon ça ça paraît de toute façon tout à
fait cohérent fois chaque et là je vais
te dire que ça y est ouf si je suis hors
théorie
force est forcément mais je serais pas
capable de jouer la position à tempo
comme comme les joueurs four b3
d'intrants détroit
douglas est archi théorique puisqu'il ya
cavaliers pro sen qui on voit qu'il ya
quand même des grosses complications les
deux dames soit en l'air et en fait
finalement ça se calme tout de suite ce
que les noirs font des rêves 5 si les
noirs font foudre en d1
regardez un peu ce qui se passe cavalier
prend des trois auraient été jouée
est sûre on attaque le fou d un mois je
peux montrer un tout c'est peut-être
plus facile vous prendrez un cas et
prenait 3 on attaque le food est un il
est obligé de prendre notre fou et nous
on prend ces cinq je pense tout fait on
on va gagner la partie donc voilà bon
les joueurs connaissent ce genre de
variantes c'est une variante
supermarchés et à la fin il y en a qui
se fait avoir pourquoi avoir en
supermarché parce que voilà on fait des
séries de prise des deux côtés et à la
fin maya soirée roues
ou alors dans le ventre supermarché
bayen des joueurs qui prend plus que
l'autre ce qui est le cas des blancs la
fin ils vont ils vont prendre un point
de plus donc les noirs connaissait ça et
puis de jouer la ronde supermarché mais
on vous aide un f5
mf5 c'est rigolo et cavalli ef trois
noms menace entre l'image et 4
c c'est assez bon c'est sans doute une
prépare des deux joueurs mais la
position elle donne quand même assez
envie avec des noirs puisque on a
l'impression qu'on a une structure
totalement symétrique et que les pièces
noires sont mieux placés
c'est factuel par contre attention il ya
une masse de g4 mais est ce bien une
menace c'est ce que jiri a voulu dire à
issy penco en jouant à tours 8 en dix
ans c'est assurément une prépa là on
alors dit qu'il me dit que c'est une
impression parce qu'on voit les petites
couleurs mais
ce g4 étaient préparés souffre
assurément avec l'idée de devenir
dégommer le roi
et la russie on connaît pas c'est hyper
dur de se faire un avis je pense que
tous les deux comme n'importe qui on
préfère les noirs parce qu'il ya une
grosse attaque sur le roi mais là faut
connaître quoi faut connaître pour
l'instant pour se lancer là-dedans droit
à agen pour le cas chez cavalli ou 5
c'est la prépa d'aniche donc on va lui
faire confiance c'est son ordi qui lui
confirme cela certains cavaliers age 2
est d'alger 6 pour garder les pièces
d'attac pas des changes de dames fous
ces deux a été jouée pour ramener une
pièce vers la défense et enlever la dame
d'attac et cavaliers detroit c'est la
réponse de n'djili
et en fait on est sous développée ici
c'est ce qu'espère aniche pour gagner
cette partie
bon vraisemblablement il ya une
nouveauté mais
je sais pas je connais pas
des
oui je peux comprendre voyez un souvenir
dit il peut y avoir des perpétuelles et
là nul peut déjà rangé les noirs ce que
je constate qu'ici penco allaire a l'air
surpris donc
il faut faire attention aux gens de
position il faut prendre les trois dames
prend des trois
toques faut prendre trois dames prend
des 3 et maintenant
je trouve que c'est pas si facile à
jouer si vous voulez côté blanc
j'ai pu en f2 en l'air j'ai le roi en
rouge je sais caniche ici connaît bien
cette position puisqu'il n'a pas dépensé
une seconde
elle fait un petit peu peur cette
position sans connaissance
c'est une position peut vraiment
s'emmêler les crayons précis et si bien
qu a montré que c'est un super joueur
donc voilà il a plus qu'à réfléchir mais
c'est une position très calculatoire si
vous voulez on n'a pas le droit trop le
droit à l'erreur donc si tu veux souffle
je mets un peu la place de cipango alors
c'est un joueur autrement plus fort que
nous mais
c'est la pression de se prendre d'avoir
un roi aussi faible dès le départ le mec
qui a pas réfléchi du tout je sais pas
quel est son niveau de connaissance
quand même si un joueur a interpellé
hier là on est quand même au 19e coup
on voit qu'il a commencé à prendre du
temps sur chaque roue il obligé de
prendre du temps d'ailleurs un petit peu
on voit ces derniers qu 11 minutes 7
minutes 3 minutes et reniche qui
bombarde pour l'instant ou alors on est
encore dans le cadre du bluff souffre et
les joueurs nous ont tous ont tous
écouter la discussion d'hier sur le
bluff dans les ouvertures et se disent
que ben ils vont faire ça toute la
journée mais non non non je crois que
cela il est vraiment il est vraiment
surpris et s'arrête encore sympa c'est
fou les positions qu'on a aujourd'hui un
souffle
sam ashton je trouve c'est le jeu qu'il
aime
moi j'aime bien le jeu à la quarantaine
avec une petit avantage je me suis
assagi depuis que j'ai 18 ans souffre de
16 à 18 je jouais comme stouff mais
après après je me suis dit allez on va
jouer on voit jouer comme magnus mais
c'est la vraie une version très discount
de magnus c'est ça le problème c'est pas
c'est pas évident et puis bon je pense
qu aux échecs vous le voyez faut avoir
tous les styles parce que la
particularité de magnus c'est qu'il
adore les positions un petit avantage
pour masser mais en fait si vous
commencez essai de basto naïve il va
commettre la cua c'est sa grande qualité
j'ai bien aimé si souvenez ton micro et
pas ouf tout fait j'ai trouvé j'ai
trouvé que c'était pas mal voilà
il en faut peu on savait mais mais
c'était bien dit
ton micro est en fait j'entends par
nécessairement ce que vous entendez
alors vous le voulez plus fort le micro
de
semer réglages là moi non mais vous
savez bien que techniquement je suis
impeccable normalement mais vous
l'entendez trop fort mais peut-être que
sophie vous dit ça il a peut-être un
micro discount ou simplement un sens on
sait pas on n'est pas là pour vérifier
ok ce que vous l'entendez trop fort pas
assez fort
[Musique]
non mes réglages ils sont au top au top
du top je pense
[Musique]
salut roots aller au bout celle d'une
agent
et
du coup je le bes un petit peu souffre
alors après vous allez me dire de
l'augmenter échange je vois arriver gros
comme une maison mais bon
on va voir on va voir
mais je me baisse un petit peu avant je
suis loin du micro mais
on va t'acheter une barre de micro mais
moi je sais que tout j'ai beaucoup de
soucis sur les histoires de son et du
coup j'ai vu comment comment vous est
certes un streamer et du coup je me suis
pris une barre pour que le micro soit
encore plus près de ma bouche et
maintenant on dit des fois que l'on
entend trop fort donc c'est insoluble
histoire en fait c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment petites galères mais l'idée
aussi ce qui est pas facile c'est
d'équilibrer les laissons des deux
micros en fait parce que quand on est
seul les gens chez eux peuvent jouer
avec le fait de de minimiser au maximum
les leçons faire des réglages et caen et
de effectivement
mais pendant la pause si vous voulez on
fera des petits tests tous les deux avec
stouff et on va on va réussir à vous
proposer
[Musique]
ouais je suis d'accord avec toi rousse
c'est mieux
ouais ça fait notre charme du goût cs
c'est pas faux c'est un stream un peu
locales au niveau de la technique voilà
c'est du stream fait maison se trouve ce
qu'on fait ce qu'on propose
est possible aussi ce qui est possible
c'est que ce soit ma connexion internet
qui est pas terrible et du
défunt que n'entend pas très très bien
mais là j'ai un problème à connaître
vraiment pas bonne les garçons en
argentine et c'est un peu compliqué et
et
je me connectais au début avec mon
téléphone en partage de connexion mais
là j'ai un problème je n'arrive plus à
payer
c'est beau ça c'est pas mal mais à
chaque fois tu me vends du rugby avec
celle des histoires se trouve celle là
elle avait pas mal que tu arrive plus à
payer j'aime bien
tu veux pas rechargez parce que tu nous
dois 500 pesos
2 à 2 euros alors ok comment je paye les
comment je paye les deux les 100 pesos
quoi et ils laissent pas payer en fait
nulle part il propose de payer ce que je
leur dois et du coup à jouer le dise non
pas parce que tu me donnes l'argent mais
laisse moi et en fait je suis bloqué je
ne peux pas leur payer ce que je leur
dois et du cou eh ben je ne peux pas
acheter des
donnez à votre avis dans le tchad est ce
que
je trouve ce n'est pas en train
d'essayer de me dire kevin laisse moins
somme laisse prague gagnait arrête de
préparer jordan et fils moi ton sobre
aujourd'hui il sait qu'on peut pas
m'acheter un que voilà c'est la compet
stouff donc ben voila je peux je peux
pas y faire grand chose moi tu as choisi
pract a choisi prague qui a un gros
espoir mais c'est ton joueur a donc
annoncé 500 pesos en plus à la bourre
pour le petit breton jeu je suis tu me
dis 500 pesos tout fait j'ai
l'impression que tu me réclame une
fortune en plus donc non non c'est pas
c'est pas possible quoi
quelle idée de s'exiler aussi tenté bit
était quand même bien tu me laisse
rêveur avec tazi soir en argentine et
même si tous nous dit que des fois que
tu as chaud je peux tour je peux te dire
que des fois on a froid nous souffrent
en ce moment donc tu as quand même cette
chance-là de régaler
en terme en termes de chaleur même si on
peut comprendre que des fois le stream
puisse être étouffant ça c'est clair et
ça y est tout feu y aura un vrai combat
dans la partie maintenant on sait on le
sait d'avancé sur un vrai combat entre
entre giry et tsypko puisque là il ya eu
vraiment une avancée majeure dans la
partie avec quatre cavaliers des f3 qui
a été jouée par ici plein pot pour
calmer la dame adverse et gagner du
temps et puis libéré le phocéen
ici et il les connaître gris il sait
qu'il n'a plus assez
pour mettre une attaque en place puisque
dès que le fou va être développé
voilà on peut mettre en place une
défense et on a une pièce de plus contre
d'options qui sont indolores donc ce
qu'a choisi guiry ces dames prend des
airs il va connaître tout reprend des
seins et faux problème de comme ça ils
piquent les trois pions à son adversaire
on peut jouer une partie un peu folle où
j'ai trois pions passé à mettre en place
parce que pour l'instant il va pas grand
chose donc c'est quoi les mettre en
place j'aimerais bien qu'il soit plutôt
avancer comme ça pour qu'il commence à
prendre de la valeur
sinon c'est la pièce y gagnera parce que
jouer avec une pièce de plus c'est quand
même assez agréable mais attention j'ai
des rentrées tour encore j'ai pas dit
mon dernier mot au niveau des pièces
mais s'arrête une partie assez folle
franchement partie hyper excitante là
encore
bien se régaler aujourd'hui un
parti
est-ce que tu tu veux qu'on aille voir
notre petit français août a atteint une
partie dans le à que tu veux absolument
aller voir souffre
du coup j'aurais pu faire un truc si
j'avais été bon
tac et voilà on y est
estoup qui rigolent et il ya de quoi y'a
de quoi par montmoreau
alors je vais vous mettre un petit mix
des carmes comme ça vous allez voir tous
les joueurs vous faire plaisir pendant
qu'on est là sur la partie de marc andré
moretti qui joue un air voix elle et les
photos des joueurs c'est des tout petits
bonhommes 1
donc marc landry encore avec avec ses
cheveux longs et son masque on voit pas
ton sac cela en fait il fait grand ado
mais la photo de mme rosine fait
vraiment petit bonhomme et
et marc andrieux en plus il a vraiment
changé physiquement je pense que tu l'a
connu aussi crâne quasi rasé
tout fait vraiment il faisait vraiment
petit bonhomme est là en un ou deux ans
il à force il a grandi et fait vraiment
presque grands ados
donc on est dans quoi là on va regarder
un petit peu ce qui s'est passé avec une
petite feinte de morzine dans le début
il commence par un des murs et y ait une
fois que que marc andré a dit qu'il a
joué cavalier f6 il fait des 4
e 6 donc là on recherche pour l'instant
unis museau et aujourd'hui ça n'arrête
pas sur ses cartes il a joué à 6
directement souffle alors c'est pas si
méconnu si vous voulez de jouer le
gambit dames avec à 6 mai avec un ordre
de kun li mu hausse est moins commun
c'est pas mal ça quand
c'est assez intelligent
enfin ça mérite l'attention en tout cas
l'intérêt c'est quoi en fait je suis en
train de me poser la question par
rapport à
qu'est-ce que ça enlève comme aux blancs
comme option
si j'avais fait des cinq civils sur le
coup si je veux un gang en midam refusé
je fais des cinq directement donc là y'a
eu à 6
1 6 beaucoup plus tard l'idée pour vous
expliquer à si ça peut être des français
enfin je vais faire des cinq du coût des
français et quand le fou va reprendre je
peux faire b5 donc là c'est
l'anticipation majeur
le faire à ce moment-là c'est hyper rare
j'ai joué l'animent zoo pendant des
lustres de cavaliers f3c lors de coups
de bogorad yen si vous faites fourbe et
cat et chaque ou de west indienne si
vous faites b6 ou de grands vides a
refusé si on fait des 5
il y avait aussi la possibilité encore
ces cinq pour revenir dans des schémas
de benoni après des 5 vous voyez
beaucoup d'options mais à 6 c'est très
rare mais aujourd'hui c'est la journée 1
souffre la la pause si je m'écoute j'ai
déjà trois choses à vérifier
que je connais pas en fait c'est pis
s'ils voulaient pas connaître ça me
dérange pas mais vous je vous l'avais
dit au départ j'estime qu'en tant
qu'entraîneur une des qualités de
l'entraîneur c'est d'avoir des
connaissances larges et là on est
surpris mais hyper tôt si vous voulez
surpris dans la partie devant de forêt
ça me dérange pas ils sont très avancés
dans la théorie c'est mail à être
surpris à chaque fois dans tôt dans la
partie de carlson c'est à vérifier et et
l'a16 bon après c'est peut-être pas
grand-chose parce qu'après qu'un essai
trois des cinq ça c'est une position que
je connais un petit peu et du coup pour
ne pas laisser les velléités de dépenser
4 au noir avec l'idée b5 ont fait ses
preuves et 5 peut prendre et 5 pour le
coup à six dans la vente des changes du
gambit dame ce qui est celle-là s'éprend
d'elle prend dès le coup à six est moins
utile je vais pas dire pas utile parce
qu'il empêche quand même de mettre en
place des attaques de minorité pour ceux
qui connaissent un an avec les noirs
jouent souvent ces six dans ces
structures d'un pion à 7 et un des plans
blancs après s'être développé
ses de balancer mes quatre baies 5
souffre du coup le coin 6 peut servir
dans ces cas là
c'est qu'on a deux pions contre 3 à bas
et on va essayer en fait de pousser des
quatre à quatre des cinq pour ouvrir
l'école années pour affaiblir du coup
les chaînes de pions noirs
voient généralement comme ça en j'ai mis
la structure en rouge parce que la
structure mollet vlas qui s'est plutôt
avec les pions à 7,17 c6 des 5
mai avec 1,6 c -
moins facile et ça nous oblige pour
l'instant moins joué aussi c'est si ça a
été jouée après coup j'ai cinq pour moi
c'est normal avant de jouer eux trois
généralement on met le fourrage et 5
aces qui est assez rigolo c'est que sur
le fou aux 6 2
de marque andry morzine le joueur russe
avec les blancs
le jeune maître russe il a joué avec g3
alors c'est un jeune maître avec 25 20
au compteur
donc on peut estimer qu'il sera grand
maître tout de suite
prochainement voilà
et du coup j'ai fait ce qui est assez
marrant c'est que j'ai 3 en règle
générale
c'est donc un système catalan mais dans
la catalane où vous savez on a un pion
ckt pions 1,6 donc c'est assez rare que
quand il ya eu les changes directement
on choisisse de mettre le fou en g2
donc on va voir quelle va être la
justification choisi par bach morzine
parce que là j'aime bien le
développement de marc-andré puisqu'il
décide de faire cavalier bdc est suivi
de fous des 6es l'interdît tout ce qui
est cavalier e 5 par contre il va
falloir qu'il fasse attention à l'idée
de la poussée de 4
mais ce que c'est un gros problème
pour l'instant non assurément donc et le
petit rock ça c'est logique
et ses six ex époux
ont pillé des pires sur cardiff et puis
on prend cavaliers prend et fawcett et
après les bleus auraient pu en isolant
des quatre voilà est un problème tout
cavalier 1 4 qui en l'air et si on
échange tout ça on va se faire suer
moi je pronostique
enfin je trouve que le début de deux
marques en dream convient bien et ça me
parait hyper solide si vous voulez c'est
moins rigolo que les partis qu'on a vu
jusqu'à présent ça va pas se mentir
c'est moins rigolo par contre
c'est très solide côté noir et je sais
pas trop pourquoi j'ai mis mon fou en g2
alors peut-être que morzine il a une
prépa sûr là dessus mais l'a pris comme
un petit peu de temps
mais j'ai du mal à justifier si tu
étouffes le fond j'ai deux
dans cette position de façon je crois
que maintenant
oui alors soit je passe par bécade
bessengue mais c'est vraiment déjà dur à
jouer on va alors qu'un valet les 2,4
peut-être vous voyez le risque qu'elle
se retrouvait avec un pion isolé sans
compensation donc c'est ouais je suis
pas très convaincu c'est étrange ce
qu'il a fait
si souvenirs je peux comment l'as tu
veux et tu peux nous oui bah voilà bah
je t'en prie souffle
bah c'est sous le nom de moi j'ai
commencé à 7 ans
entre 6 et 7 je sais pas exactement
en club à septembre c'est sûr
qui t'a pris sous le feu du culte a
appris au club ou alors tu as appris
avec un bouquet de fleurs qu'il
y avoir à peu près mille six cent est
donc d'accord et donc il m'a appris à
jouer et dans mon aiguille on compte peu
des maçons des pièces c est à 7 ans je
suis allé m'inscrire au club donc
j'étais à nice est checké niçois est
donc donc voilà c'est avec
marc liste qui que j'ai commencé ce
parce qu'il a connu si enfin le nom le
nom enfin ils étaient 24 je crois de
1420 ouais ça le mélo c'est pour ça j'ai
déjà vu mais on en est loin avec stouff
un toit c'est nice c'était la bretagne
donc mais le nom du coup je le voyais de
ce joueur très régulièrement dans les
villes américaines quoi
donc et dot a commencé quand toi alors
beaucoup plus jeune mais avec mon père
mon père il a jamais joué en club sauf
en retraite mais bon quand quand il m'a
appris il avait il avait une trentaine
d'années donc moi g
j'ai appris comment dirais-je quand
j'avais 4 ans et demi tu vois quand
j'étais vraiment petit et pendant deux
ans je joue avec mon père en fait comme
ça des petites parties lui joue avec ses
couleurs collègues de boulot si tu veux
stuff et en fait j'ai démarré en club un
petit peu comme toi donc en un petit
poussin deuxième année donc dans l'année
de mes sept à huit ans et ça c'est
directement bien passé puisque comme
jouer avec avec mon père qui avait un
tout petit niveau peut-être 1600 1200
mah déjà quand je suis arrivé en petits
poussins
gt gt vraiment performant et j'ai gagné
je peux un régional j'ai pas fait le
choix de france et ça c'est dommage
parce que j'avais gagné avec 7 sur 7
donc j'étais bouillon mais j'ai dû
attendre deux ans après pour faire le
france poussins où j'ai fini neuvième
mais à l'époque en bretagne les échecs
n'était pas hyper structuré et du coup
j'étais dans un tout petit club qui avec
une fusion avec un autre club a grandi
et du coup j'ai bénéficié de deux mètres
10 à 18 ans d'un bad à des conseils d'un
pur bénévoles entraîneurs
qui m'a beaucoup aidé est qu'il y avait
1 et l'autre de 1200 si tu veux et avant
j'ai aussi plusieurs personnes à 1800
2000 on va dire qu'ils m'ont qui m'ont
donné des petits coups de main mais
c'était pas des pros mais il ya surtout
une personne qui m'a beaucoup aidé
et du coup
ça m'a permis
d'avoir des cours structuré mais
d'échanger d'analyser et il avait une
particularité donc chaque boulot reste
un joueur qui est assez connu en
bretagne qui a eu à l onas un même à
2300 tu vois donc quelqu'un qui était
costaud et il a une particularité il
avait un jeu un peu enlevée as tout faux
il balance est quasiment une pièce par
parti tu vois souffre vraiment il ils
étaient cinglés dans son approche du jeu
il voulait prendre un max de plaisir est
par contre tout ce qui est jeu à la 40
scènes du musée autour d'une faiblesse
ce n'était pas son école donc c'est un
peu l'école bretonne que je vous propose
parce qu'on a tous eu trait là il a déjà
formé pas mal de jeunes en plus de la
région et on est connu en bretagne pour
avoir un jeu un peu cochon voilà ça va
bien et que la bretagne je pense tout ce
que je dis là on essaye de tout balancer
on joue agressif on n'aime pas les
parties plan plan moi je sais que j'ai
changé à partir de mes 18 ans justement
je suis devenu beaucoup plus plan-plan
stouffer j'ai fait pas mal de progrès
positionné à cet âge là alors qu'avant
c'étaient les attaques sur le roi qui
m'intéressait aux échecs j'ai un style
un peu plus complet avec l'âge mais
malheureusement c'est pas facile de
progresser faut beaucoup joué aussi mais
au début c'était la baston la baston
voilà ce qu'on aime en bretagne la
grosse baston les grosses attaques la
partie de marc andrieu alexis très pas
beaucoup de joueurs bretons par exemple
a pas se mentir
[Musique]
il n'est plus assez fort
et je m'applique cocoa je trouve des
titres maintenant avant je faisais pas
trop attention à ça mais j'essaie de
trouver des petites mares en maintenant
pour les vidéos youtube
ouais mais a jadis je sais pas si
vraiment tous ceux qui sont passionnés
des chaque dans le chatt franchement
avec se trouve on peux pas vous dire le
contraire que d'aller jouer en plus de
votre pratique récréative sur le web
dalé
intégrer un club si c'est possible au
niveau de votre emploi du temps perso si
si vous êtes vraiment passionné ça peut
changer votre approche du jeu
et cela dans tous les domaines moi à
titre perso
je les fais pour le badminton puisque
j'adore ça je pense que c'est la bonne
démarche vraiment si vous êtes
passionnés dans un domaine allait
rencontrer du monde autour de votre
passion allait jouer des joueurs
expérimentés
vous allez prendre des bonnes branle et
je peux vous l'assurer ça marche comme
ça dans tous les domaines ce qui a des
joueurs de clubs qui sont rompus dans
leur discipline on a dit avec stouff on
a commencé tout jeune et on fait
beaucoup beaucoup d'échecs encore
aujourd'hui même si on est en tant que
joueur préretraités on va dire mais
sinon franchement c'est un super
conseille d'aller en d'aller en club
faut le faire quoi vous avez compris les
super ça ne s'est
classée que moi je peux comprendre
comprendre que ça fasse peur d'aller en
club mais en fait le seul conseil qu'on
peut donner si vous aimez en fait si
vous aimez assez le jeu ben vous allé
vaincre votre peur et et faire cette
démarche là si tenté que vous n'êtes pas
gêné par une vie active
trop prenante une vie perso prenantes
aussi parce que je peux comprendre que
quand on est actif quand on a une
famille et cetera et cetera que ça soit
pas si facile d'aller au club d'échecs
des frondes n'a pas assez proche de chez
soi après ça c'est tout les condamne
mais si vous avez la possibilité
allez-y et après j'espère que le club
d'échecs sera le plus accueillant
possible dans le sens où me laissera
assez gros pour vous offrir des
partenaires de jeu des partenaires
d'entraînement et une structuration
assez assez importante qui vous
permettent de vous épanouir voilà voilà
on retourne dans le en maintenant qu'on
a vu cette partie de la marque andry et
puis on va plus s'endormir car a donné
une partie assez rigolote cette visite à
les aimants on retourne et on va aller
voir
bien sûr beaucoup qu'on peut être un
club enfants débutants injustement ça
sert à ça il ya beaucoup de clubs après
sais pas où tu habites beaucoup montré
ya beaucoup de clubs sont formateurs
aussi des cours dont des cours tous
niveaux adultes jeunes et c'est donc du
coup je pense qu'ils devraient essayer
de deux tournées vers un club de ta
région ça n'existait pas une certaine
époque mais maintenant les clubs avons
été entraînés par des bénévoles à notre
époque des dinosaures
mais maintenant il ya beaucoup de
formateurs en école des animateurs dans
les clubs donc si le club est assez
structuré a assez gros normalement vous
devriez comme disent tous fils trouver
votre bonheur
alors je trouve que tu voulais aller
voir cette variante est là je vais être
bien plus compétents encore que c'est
encore une prépa de vie puisqu'il à 1h40
kong en ait lieu mais rien à partir
c'est plutôt quand d autres ce qui est
sûr c'est de la merde mais il va
connaître
visite est ce que tu penses qui lui a
fait la fox est ce que tu fais ce qu'il
appelle la fin non hélas 1h40 toujours
la fin de compte aujourd'hui il ya que
ça donc avalé b d2 alors c'est un
système hyper mal hein je monte ça
quelques des élèves contre les joueurs
qui balance le fou au funk et au
normalement grande elle use d'ailleurs
il est connu il aime bien montrer les
muscles grande île où il veut des
parties fight et là cavalier mais deux
je t'annonce que je veux jouer e4
et du coup c'est hyper énervant parce
que l'idée c'est que si les noirs pour
empêcher le 4 parce que je joue de 400
ces quatre donc plutôt des systèmes pire
que modern pas très excitant pour les
noirs du coup souvent les joueurs jouent
des 5 et là je peux jouer des schémas
avec b 4e 3 b 4 et compagnie et si vous
retomber là-dedans généralement b400
pêche tous les c5 et la rupture clés au
centre dans ses positions là et là les
blancs vont s'amuser avec ses quatre
derrière à 4 du jeu elle dame et les
noirs sont un peu resserré or ces
schématique ce que je vous donne mais
globalement c'est assez désagréable donc
je vois que le grenelle us à jouer rouge
et
7e 4 et cette position n'est absolument
pas marrant normalement
et là il a joué petit rock petit rock
alors je sais pas si on peut dire que
ces grands des lieux ce qui a foutu la
merde en fait si tu veux se trouvent
parce que là c'est vrai qu'il pouvait
jouer des six pour éviter le 5 mai non
les sacs ont pas si bonne presse que
cela ah si si si si si si royal là c'est
vrai qu'on préfère jouer des six pour
l'éviter à chaque fois parce qu'il a une
idée quand même que j'ai déjà regardé si
tu enlèves le calme règne en fils parce
que normalement poussé au pion centre
qui s'essouffle il ya des décisions qui
vont arriver pour exposer le centre donc
c'est pas sûr que ce soit toujours bon
mais là il ya une idée qui est sympa
alors il ya cavaliers des cinq aux
cavaliers 8
km et l'es5 ce doit être un petit peu
mieux et en fait on peut déjà jouer les
idées abbas un jour 2 h 4 h 5 et c4
aussi chez quelques le redis j'ai
regardé ses quatre croit mme kébé 6 ses
cinq jeux c'est bizarre mais des trucs
comme ça
et on prend une emprise centrale on à
l'initiative il ya toujours ce plan hqe
attachant qui peut exister et sur
cavaliers à 8 sur re5 je crois qu'on
peut jouer h 4 h anne de bois mais avec
l'idée à chaque et
c'est un bordel en fait
je prétends rien du tout un ici mais je
prétends que c'est compliqué que c'est
chaud et du coup un cavalier à chaque
samedi rien en fait
j'étais parti
avec
5 mais là là c'est que si tu veux tu
ouvres ton jouer cavalier à chaque camp
jeudi un indice qu'est ce qui a souvent
c'est le pion f3 qui a bougé tu vois
avec dédain match 4 par exemple c'est
l'exemple grossier mais là il n'y a rien
dans la structure qui indique qu'on peut
jouer cavalier h5 et que ça se fait
tranquille où on a même peur de ce coup
d'équilibriste en fait
hockey est sûr que cav a lieu quatre
lits décédés 6 et on contrôle g4 et on
ne perd pas le cavalier
en fouet c'est peut-être ça peut
permettre un f6 après fin du délire pur
quoi vous voyez c'est là là ce qu'on
vous montrent désolé mais c'est contre
les principes du jeu d'échecs cavaliers
à chacun là pour le coup
cavaliers au bord cavaliers morts c'est
vrai alors là il a une case de rebond
mais on peut lui enlever sa case de
rebond donc c'est hyper dur de vous
expliquer et vulgariser ce genre de coup
c'est quand même un coup d'équilibriste
réservé à une élite mondiale ou alors à
de très bons joueurs amateurs qui ont
brossé la position avec le redis
c'est tu connais pas c'est injouable
il ya eu g4 non mg3 et pas ridicule avec
le blocus du cavalier à chaque foulée de
et petits rocks à jour est bon il a dû
bosser mais c'est pas ridicule
jeu pour répondre des systèmes six
essais
ouais mais
c'est plus concret quoi bon alors là là
c'est le coup critique en fait comme 10
toof
goût congrès coup critique qui pose la
vraie question j'ai quatre cavaliers f4
ton cavaliers il est encore en l'air
cavalier e 4 et là les joueurs
connaissaient et puisque regarder le
bordel que nous mais grand des lieux
s'il est connu pour ça il fait des 5es
du coup les deux cavaliers sont en l'air
et en qu'il ya une prise en passant
possible et peut-être que surprise en
passant son idée s'était reprise avec
l'idée tours 8
parce qu'en fait il cavaliere et f4 en
l'air mais je pense qu'il aurait pris 2
e pour récupérer sa pièce virtuellement
grâce à ce clonage imaginons je prends
stouff bat tours 8 et il ya des 5 qui
arrive ou f5 et il ya aussi fou projet 4
mais on va se refaire un autre retard
avec cette idée là
c'est chaud déjà franchement voyez la
iraqi doivent se dire ouais super chaud
donc la vie dit il à calmer le jeu il a
juste enlever son cavalier se cavalière
cadre est en l'air il n'y a pas beaucoup
de cases en plus il a que la 15 6
et là c'est de la folie furieuse parce
que bon moi j'étais en train de regarder
c'est peu dire je n'ai pas encore vu le
coude tout fait je me disais
non ch4 quelque chose et là les deux
joueurs connaissent je pense parce que
vie dit qu'on a regardé la partie là
avec stouff qui nous l'a proposé il y
avait une heure 39 donc il connaît tout
ou quasiment tout ce que la position est
extrêmement complexe on ne peut pas se
lancer là-dedans l'aveuglette cavaliers
f5 a été joué deux points d'exclamation
apparemment pour au niveau des couleurs
duchess comme d'aucuns mallié f5 si vous
voulez sur gée problème j'éprouvais fait
il annonce qui as en l'air qui a
peut-être une attaque de maths ça clique
sur l'hyper for ipad quatre cavaliers
folie furieuse franchement très très
beau choix de partie oui on promet on
promet qu'il y aura
arnaud arnaud ils nous surveillent comme
souvent arnaud il est bien
on
promet qui aura pu mêlant peut pas là on
peut pas arnaud je suis désolé en plus
ça nous raison de nous faire un rappel à
l'ordre ont le mérite mais on est obligé
de rester à regarder ça parce que là on
a des yeux d'enfant quand on regarde une
partie comme ça et sur cette attaque
deux allèles de vie dite grand des lieux
se joue la réaction au centre c'est
juste de la folie furieuse donc cavalier
pranger sept cavaliers prend d'accord on
se retrouve avec lecavalier en fouillant
piétons il aura navigué ans cavalier 1
rappelons son chemin jusqu'à présent
bien opinion bien bon s'est bien amusé
avec lecavalier normalement ce qu'on dit
c'est qu'il faut essayer de pas bouger
plusieurs fois la même pièce dans
l'ouverture tant qu'on n'a pas sorti
toutes ces pièces mineurs sauf s'il ya
vraiment une grosse opportunité
bombe à la grande hélios avait
l'opportunité de faire le clown avec son
cavalier il l'a saisie mais c'est
vraiment on aime bien et c'est le
vulgariser les parties de haut niveau
voilà c'est juste voilà faut regarder ça
comme un joli film parce que c'est très
difficile à comprendre et je pense que
même pour les joueurs c'est difficile à
comprendre mais qu'ils ont énormément
bossé ses positions calculatoire est pas
naturelle 1 je crois c'est juste pour
défendre les cartes est coincé le fou
qui on donne pas les cases aux cavaliers
donc on bouge pas le pion g4 s'éprend
des pour casser le centre et fois
schiste pour continuer l'attaquons
reprendra qu'on veut
est ok pour x 1,6 et la brillant coup de
grands delius damas cinq comme ça il se
prendra pas de grosses attaques soient
gfu des deux soit qui a aidé 2 mais dans
ce cas là je rêvais pièces de l'attak
donc il a préféré vie dit faire dam des
deux quais sur dame prend cavaliers pro
d2
aucun doute le trac mais il a toujours
la tournée se passe exactement un euro
et se pions là ils considèrent qu'ils
valent regagner un souffle un jour quoi
et le cavalier aussi ce qui épate les
pâtes riz en place et en plus y'a
toujours un beau la poussée de foot en
cavalier au cas où
mais même le fou c'est u2 voyez qu'il a
du mal à avoir un avis y est donc
donc quand rock avec les baies 3 f 4g de
on va vendre le dessin qui
se passe donc à laisser si ces six f4 f6
efficace grande des lieux c'est obligé
d'être entreprenants dans cette position
puisque sur le long terme on voit que
vie dit il a plus d espace il a aussi
la paire de flou et la structure noir
est plus fragile je pense que les blancs
vont tout simplement se refaire en
termes d'équilibré matériel rétablir un
équilibre matériel et ensuite profiter
de leurs meilleures activités du
al'avantage de l'espace et de la paire
de fou
en fait des must et une partie père
enlevé en train de se calmer avec gros
avantage blanc parce que je sais pas
j'ai peur de te prends un grand roque
cavaliers mais trois que stouff cité et
après je suis bientôt prendre des cats
et être vraiment mieux se trouve donc il
va falloir être très entreprenant de la
part de nils cornelius s'il veut se
sortir de de ce beau guêpier mais ça
mériterait d'être revu le film qu'on
vous a montré assez vite
ça mériterait d'être un peu patient pour
expliquer tous écoutent cavaliers en
tout cas grand des lieux s'il a été très
ambitieux dans le début et ça se
retourne un peu contre lui j'ai
l'impression
on va vous envoyer du coup la pub
souffre c'est ça qu'on fait yes on va y
aller nos vaches et ouais on fait la pub
et boubou après la pub on
on répond à ta question c'est promis
allez on vous dit a tout de suite et on
vous balance après cinq minutes de pub
a tout de suite
[Musique]
il
vous
[Musique]
m
e
oh
[Musique]
non
on
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en
[Musique]
oh
où
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
et
et on est reparti avec stouff pour les
commentaires du tata steel
et ça chauffe un petit peu sur
l'échiquier de deux magnus en tout cas
il a été récompensé de son sacrifice
puisqu'elle a réussi à revenir en termes
matériels déjà et la position assez
complexe stouff déjà il avait moyen au
dernier coup de
de piquet de piquer la paire
puisqu'il aurait pu jouer vraiment
différemment quand il y avait un
cavalier en d5 ils pouvaient aussi
piqué la paire de fous je suis en train
de regarder la partie dallas à la pause
là quand il y avait la pub ce que je
voulais voir un petit peu souffre au
niveau théorique ce que ça donnait il ya
vraiment tellement de façons de donner
un pion dans l'ouverture tarrach
de gormiti et là je sais que l'ordi
proposé qu'à m et 4 pour piquer le fou
de cases blanches et jouer après sur la
couleur très ouverte
ma blanche évidemment puisque quand pic
le fou sur une couleur de l'adversaire
et bien évidemment forcément
c'est c'est
c'est les cases blanches qu'ils doivent
souffrir
des mousses montante a beaucoup manqué
dans pendant pendant la pause mais aussi
et il aime pas trop il n'aime pas trop
la pub il n'aime pas trop la pub et web
assez il ya des pubs incompressibles / /
/ chess comme ça fait partie aussi de
bas de la vie du stream a généralement
fait des pubs du coup sûr sûr qu'elle
ait cinq petit rock et cavaliers
français 3 plutôt que cavalier bekkat
hockey du couffo b2 et maintenant
bah va y avoir une petite pression quand
même blanche puisque il ya un retard de
développement chez magnus alors il va
falloir voir comment comment ils
comptent jouer cette position peut-être
cavaliers à 4 pour pour piquer le four
b2 il ya quand même un problème de
développement
notamment comme dans la partie hier deux
trades contre maintenus sera ce fameux
plongée c'est être inquiété en prise
avec le fougueux donc à youtube et 4 qui
permet de garder la prédation de roquet
et sans perdre le set faut juste
vérifier maintenant les histoires de
naudin
b3d
3way manger peut-être un problème madame
1 je peux me faire je peux me faire
piquer la dame si je fais à 3 il ya
défaut à quatre il ya des fous 1,6
dans mes trois ça donne envie mais c'est
peut-être
c'est est hyper chaud
et est ce que j'ai le droit de faire le
coup interdit souffle
le co est interdit neuf coups interdits
c'est quoi ici c'est fou quand achat de
bons alors d'un côté ce qui est
intéressant avec ce coup en faucon à vii
c'est que
[Musique]
parce que j'ai pas dû x 4
thèmes des trois encore
en fait je
bouge ton cavaliers g d'arcade sur x 4
effectivement d'amd 3
et sur les six autres projets cissé mais
comme j'ai davantage de développement
pourrait me permettre
mais on peut dire ça j'ai dit ce que
magnus il n'aime pas trop sacrifier il
n'a pas si la mv est là ça fait tout le
temps mais là tu vois la jouer avec un
pion de moi il m on peut dire qu'ils
préfèrent des positions de jeux de
construction opposition
combinatoire calculatoire ce qui ne veut
pas dire comme il est numéro un mondial
que il ne gère ni
enfin qu'il ne gère pas la tactique ni
le calcul il est très fort partout mais
très complet mais particulièrement plus
fort que ses adversaires du top 10 dans
le jeu de construction
les plus fiables dans ses positions la
voilà ce qu'on peut dire
alors gmt une truie remarques
c'est du calcul là il faut qu'on engage
set je pensais à fou à 4
et est sûre fois que je pensais à dam
des trois mais là je les
nomme de 3 c'est pas illogique pour
proposer les changes de dame quand même
mais 5
fu b5 oui mais il rate un bon début mais
tour prend pas plus de coups en fait sur
un tour prend des buts je crois de
souffler
ouais bon en garde c'était c'était chaud
regarder une petite innovation texte ouf
mais sarah c'est vraiment un déjà
d'amener 3 je propose est fourbe et 5
pour les noirs
dame prend des huit tours en 1 8 surtout
ces trois fous ces trois je me suis
cramé le foie achète le
être trop de pièces emprise ont
peut-être revenir avant
déjà pas en d3 qu'on doit aller
qui vous est à près de 9,5
peut-être mieux parce qu'il ya des dames
5 tout le temps ouais mais j'ai pour ces
cinq là ce concept a pas d'échec un
an quel bazar damage trois bons coups
ouais j'avais pas vu tour c'est cinq
fois
qu'est ce que c'est compliqué parce que
j'ai même cavalier 5 à la limite sur
tours c'est 100 initialement compliqué
que voyez c'est le bazar total mais fo
prend achète c'est pas si ridicule on
vous prend achète
séparer dès que le doux chant corse il
intrigue assez conservateur donc je le
vois pas s'envoyer en l'air là dedans
sur le compte 40 chaînes
je ne vois pas l'intérêt de fond qu'on
achète si vous voulez y a pas g6
interdit le petit rock et ceux qui ont
peur des découvertes du cavalier c3 vous
avez tout le temps de me 4 et bim
donc ça fait ça fait mal
ça fait vraiment mal
du coup dans cette
dans cette pause
place et c'est pas forcément c'est pas
forcément si facile que cela
fout croates chez eux j'aime bien mais
j'ai foi 4 c'est quand même très très
compliqué
on est on est même parasité par la jauge
que vous voyez un dans ses positions là
on audi en tout cas le radis préfère des
blancs mais sans doute de f 5
tours c5 trouver parce tout fait là il
fallait trouver le coup mais c'est pas
la joie sans doute c'est bien pour les
banques voient que les pièces noires
sont hyper bizarre mais il faut trouver
le coup gagnant j'ai pensé à claire-voie
lieu 5 mais bon je fouillais même des
coups comme dame s'est tu sais je me
disais que ça n'allait pas trop alors
c'est l'incroyable la position qu'on
allait jouer ça ou ça
les positions complexes on peut craquer
regardez je suis en train de dire d'un
f4 ou d'objets 4s tout m'a gentiment
repris pour la belle merguez envoyez-les
avec damas quatre cavaliers de hi hi hi
cavaliers de la franchise royal vous
voyez on peut faire des gros gros oubli
cours d imposition comme ça très
calculateur alors que dame jacques a par
contre fait hyper mal
je crois que je touche j'étais assez
inspiré de proposer fou prend achète
c'est peut-être le coup de la position
en fait
je crois bien parce que si vous voulez
vous prend achète ses
76 positionnelle mais
normands ont fait pas ça mais en fait ce
qui m'a conduit à le faire c'est que
tous les découvertes du cavalier me
faisait peur mais si je fais fou prend
1,7 g dames 4 derrière sur les
découverts de cavaliers donc ça ne peut
pas fonctionner découverte de cavaliers
après ce qui va jouer ça parce que là je
filme un c'est pas mes pièces un
noyé par c'est pas mes pièces on
sous-entend qu'on n'est pas en partie
contre magnus si on peut faire vous
prend h est bon après pour tout fait moi
si on était contre magnuson pourrait se
permettre de faire un coup comme ça
parce que c'est un peu la partie de
d'une vie et du coup pourquoi pas
envoyer mais objectivement jean-claude
notre état d'esprit là les blancs contre
manu s'il a envie de faire une grosse
partie n'a pas envie de tout [ __ ] en
l'air quoi parce que nous c'est notre
chance
c'est notre chance ok on va essayer on
va entendre quoi mais bon chaque clan
bon lune bleue ni votre champ kong et
carlson il est il ya un fossé entre le
devoir mais sur une partie avec les
blancs chaque fois on peut largement
tenir et même gagner jadis il faut b 5
mois pour tous vous avez j'avais
beaucoup d'idées de foot français 3 aidé
à me 4 mais là je suis vraiment pas
obligé
georges a dit s'il veut me faire un
p'tit coup de cavaliers de discret parce
qu'il a vu que j'avais pas vu la
fourchette donc il se dit tiens on va
décoller
même de 9 5 est intéressant ici
comme tout rebond assez compliqué cette
position
non il a ils attaquent f1 et la case de
hyper complexe fous ces trois fous ces
trois
peut-être d'un b3
du protoss à b4
et ce tous nous mais un beau bordel mais
il y aura toujours ça en l'air aussi
maman et peut-être que c'est 3 g dames
e4 aussi des bazars total en tout cas on
voit qu'il ya un grand
kevin ce que tu as pu rater à la fin
c'est que je sais moi ça j'ai vu j'ai vu
sur la gelée la gelée vu plus loin non
pour l'instant je n'ai pas été aussi
catégorique que sur le dal f4 ou je me
suis pris cavaliers eux deux en un
mais
là on est quand même
avec des petites des petites
complications
il ya clic au top gm qui aiment
sacrifier à paris richard rapporte
mamediarov
il y en a plusieurs anaky qui envoie
salut à toi je n'avais pas vu avant dans
le chat mais
du boeuf
moi y'en a qui ont des cils très
caractéristique d'attac mais c'est vrai
que maxime c'est un des meilleurs
calculateur du top mondial et du coup
quand vous avez des facilités de
calculer facilité du jeu combinatoire
bas vous allez dans les positions
agressives preuve en est son répertoire
grunfeld nage dorff qui est plutôt un
père thouars basé sur le jeu le jeu
complexe et il n'a pas joué alors
champion depuis juste rafraîchir nom est
toujours en train de plancher sur sur
fou bekkat
s'aperçoit peut-être de quelque chose
quand même hein en tout cas
magnus avec prix quand même un petit
risque
pénal un joueur comme sanglant il faut
prendre des risques quand même être
champion il joue solide 1 c'est un très
très bon joueur et il faut quand même
aller chercher un il nous arrive avait
un peu d'appréhension à cette chercher
des les
je pense est déstabilisé le mot
est ce qu on fait un petit tour sur les
autres partis juste peau les parties
qu'on n'a pas été voir jusqu'à présent
on peut déjà dire que du beauf et duda
tu me l'a dit à la pause mais ça va
ça va vraisemblablement faire match nul
à
je vois pas cette partie on peut montrer
vite fait la position
elle paraît vraiment hyper égales entre
douba off qui a perdu par forfait hier
et du coup bon tu dois être quand même
moins
moins intéressé par tournoi dans sa
globalité il doit avoir moins d'ambition
à cause de ce coup d'arrêt et d'autre
part duda qui a perdu hier qu'ils
allaient pièce noire qui ne devrait pas
être content se refaire une qui devrait
pas de compte se refaire et faire match
nul pour cela salut super look bling du
coup
on se retrouve dans cette situation
après cas et des cinq qui annonce vas-y
sont échangées tous les pièces pour
faire nul voila bon bah on revient pas
de
dessus et on n'a pas été voir cariat qui
ne rapportent depuis le départ
c'est possible je dise que shankland
calcul cela
est du coup pour l'instant vous avez à
la cam on va vite fait voir cariat qui
ne rapporte je vous met un terme de
karuïa qui ne rapportent mais ils sont
aussi très concentrée et après on
reviendra sur le fil rouge par exane
nuss alors qu'est ce qui se passe dans
cette partie je voyais bien car yakine
faire faire une petit à petit de master
class et s'est pas encore impossible
parce que ok vous voyez la jauge qui qui
est vraiment très
porté sur l'égalité
mais on va quand même dans une situation
où j'ai cavaliers contre le fou qui dort
un petit peu
bon la sueur b prend 1 à 5 d'ailleurs
j'aurais ce plan là
et après là je peux jouer vraiment pour
gagner cette position attention hein
j'ai mon courage car pour l'instant en
l'air il ya des choses mais
ça paraît
ouais ça paraît quand même est une
position de travail temps ci et noah et
puis jouer tout reprend 1,5 mais pour
l'instant il ya peut-être le pion b6 en
l'air ce parce que calcul
ouais méprisant à 56 tours à huit mais
tu vas jouer ça que c'est ce qu'ils
regardent vraisemblablement parce que
apprend des cinq tours b des provinces
avec des cinq souffrir ouais c'est ça il
ya des cases vous voyez donc là aussi
pour faire nul plus facilement serait
bien que rapporte essaie de prendre de
la tour de laisser ce qui est en train
de vérifier il permet 6 mai après 3,8 il
regagne option à 4 en force avec toutes
ces pièces dessus et là ça irait
vraisemblablement peut-être plus
facilement pour la nulle
dans le cadre d'épreuves
il ya plusieurs problèmes mis en avant
passant ses cinq pour le cavalier dans
le futur il ya le fait de poster la tour
pour travailler les deux faiblesses des
noirs même si tours c4 est possible donc
bah il n'a pas réussi à regagner le pion
en force qui fait mes points et
maintenant on va pouvoir travailler
assurément et voilà le coup de stouff
joué par cariat clean deux joueurs à la
grande technique souvent quand on pense
à kariat qui n'ont pensa stouff derrière
voilà c'est ça qu'on dit je crois
la même style au même site à lille même
style même s'il a la même école la même
école l'école niçoise et l'école russe
voilà on confond souvent conseil est
souvent une confusion entre les deux
écoles
a
priori de bêtises
laurent fait en un tour où je pensais à
foug 17 pour qu un sens qu'il faut
prendre à 4 mais elle oublie qu'il est
le pion des sacs aussi en crise
ouais mais fou des fous 17 sais pas si
bête
si tout reprend des cinq d'irak qui
avait poussé 6 quoi weeks a donc à voir
mais il a dû le regarder il a dû le
regarder en france à 17 dont surtout
reprend 1,5 qui voulait faire quoi et
avec
la partie ça va se jouer
fu 17 il va jouer tourbe est en berne il
faut aussi y retrouver ses
parents n'étaient pas gaza c'est vrai
non mais c'est cfoot pas non mais tu
veux ma part rien sommes là dessus je le
refus je refuse le gagner je viens de
gagner
est-ce que tu laisses me coûte non mais
là c'est non je fais pas bien sûr bien
sûr bien sûr bien sûr mais en fait je te
file un seul contre rien du tout si à ça
franchement tu as ta tro bien vu tu
mérites ton seul le méritons seb et moi
j'aurais le droit doit dire un truc un
peu bise un moment et de nulle part est
de gagner un sommet mais ça devrait du
même acabit parce que l'idée incroyable
mais juste sur fou 17 tours prend 1,5 à
arriver quoi
baver lui [ __ ] on a quatre
tâches je vois même pas l'idée alors
attends je regarde ce qu'est ce que
c'est que ça
[Rires]
prend des deux tours plus non
et heureusement que j'ai refusé le seul
sinon les gens dans le chat ils m'ont
aurait voulu de profiter
chez pas
à la à la pause il ya eu du chott de
rome ils font du rhum en argentine
souffre ou quoi est-ce qu'il y aura
marre jantes inquiets qui existent il
faut le faire naître
et par là et en a parlé mais j'ai appris
spector j'ai appris il ya deux jours
j'étais choquée j'ai appris qu'en fait
que que le fernet et bien c'est pas
argentin mais italien et
maison la fabrique de m
mais moi les gens qui m'en parlent et se
l'approprier
les argentins si je comprends bien ils
ont ils ont une grande gueule comme les
français quoi je trouve c'est ça qui est
en train de me dire
le matin porte du café avec des plantes
avec le maté il évoque beaucoup
l'argentine mais aussi en uruguay et au
paraguay samedi quelque chose
effectivement chaque pays dit que c'est
eux qui l'ont
mais en tout cas
vous avez vu le le pari de stouff un fou
17 au tour b un fou aux six tours b5 et
match et match nul non mais si c'est ça
archi méritée ce sommet
avec l'explication reprend 1,5 du fou
prend 1,4 je me disais je me disais je
vais quand même un doute au début de
l'action parce que je me dis mais je
peux prendre des deux tours donc j'ai
malentendus et qui coulent autant
surtout prenez 5 pouces et si c'était
hyper chaud mais là il ya une petite
blague il ya une petite blague
j'ai fait une faute de calcul donc du
coup si vraiment vraiment ça se passe là
c'est fait je vois que
[Rires]
je crois pas je crois pas ça pour ça que
j'ai pas voulu même matin une petite
côte c'était vraiment le
le soft gratuit ce rappel le soft
gratuit chaque jour le soft gratuit
ok on voit petit pressing de deux
canadiens ont fait un petit bonjour un
petit rebond jours
un marc andré mauric dit on va voir
magnus allez allez allez
et rebonjour
marque andry et je vais mettre le le mix
des calmes comme ça vous va tout le
monde pendant qu'on est sur la partie de
de marc-andré mao rizzi et
peut-être un tout petit pressing blanc
même pas
je peux non mais rien du tout hein mais
je suis je suis toujours étonné un dans
la structure de voir le fou angers de
chercher parce que ça lui a apporté
j'ai pas compris et puis dépendre tout à
l'heure quand il l'a fait et il ne le
fait pas comprendre si tu veux souffre
ce choix assez étonnant
- il faut faire les bons échanges parce
que
il ya déjà une proposition structurelle
à ce que j'ai envie de donner ce coup là
je peux c'est
censé être mon mauvais fou mais dans
quel sens je peux aussi prendre d'abord
est ce que j'ai envie
dans ce cas il prendra sans doute dû
plonger
pour jouer un plan comme ça sur le roi
sur le roi noir
donc je peux prendre je peux disait de
prendre une fois mais la dame elle sera
un peu pénible ici à gérer
du coup c'est pas si facile de
réagir dans cette position
un bon petit travail qui est fait par
par le joueur avec
un règle et blanc il joue sur quoi
finalement comme n'y a pas vraiment de
faiblesses sur le roi il améliore les
pièces si l'on amène un petit peu mais
pas de quoi mater
amélioration des pièces et il n'oublie
pas de bien regarder ses pions
son objectif c'est véritablement
pas de changer la structure pour avoir
des perspectives je pense qu'il veut
jouer sur la colonne g
ce serait 4g pourrait être quatre avec
walt enfouis f3 watch
ce qui pourrait être pas mal passé avec
son cavalier c'était un avis postés en 5
i/s
cas relief sa pensée plutôt malin et
puis là
je sais pas
quel échange le plus favorable pour nous
voilà la question qu'on doit qu'on doit
se poser est ce qu on veut échanger deux
pièces une seule pourquoi
cavaliers 17 devrait revenir aussi
peut-être par f8 g6
fou 17 par rapport
à l'or
il a vraiment joué ou pas
je préfère attendre un petit peu
voire bon donc marc andry vous voilà
c'est une partie équilibrée pour
l'instant et on va retourner
pas du tout aimé ou pas du tout tomber
son blog ses sept tours c5 ça serait
beau qui est nul mais différemment tu
sais tout ça c'est rigolo je
rigolerai
mais non il y aura un pressing de karuïa
keane assurément un petit pressing là on
va avoir droit
ou d'un bep 6 avec tour des cinq nuls
comme ça pas impossible a déconné en
ammar ami et ex cavaliers
après comme les six tours b 5 dans ses
sept tours 5 au final n'aura la même
position
c'est pas faux c'est pas faux mais non
c'est un peu parce que tu nous as mintel
une telle merguez avec fu 17 la sec
c'était
c'était vraiment
c'était non je fais pas accepté je suis
désolé mais là je pense qu'il veut
amener ces pièces de toute façon il va y
va essayer de jouer un peu carrière
qu'il n'y a pas de raison c'est une
position à 2 résultant voit que c'est
les blancs qui est qu'ils sont un petit
peu mieux il ya peut-être pas assez à
leur niveau d'accord mais y'a de quoi et
c'est un petit peu
allez on veut on retourne voir la partie
ça fait longtemps qu'on n'a pas été voir
son petit poulain par yolanda ça se
passe bien pour lui ou ou pas ont
peut-être
que tu nous en parle pas c'est que c'est
c'est que ça a c'est sans doute sans
doute pour près d'un mandat oui
on a vu la jauge de s'exciter dès qu'on
arrivait dans la partie
et on avait parlé de cette rupture f3 on
va voir la tête de prague 90 da
ilha il est il est scotché le petit et
mamediarov et les parties boit un coup
pareil alors on était dans une anglaise
qui ont été arrêtés dans cette position
où après b5 on s'attendait quand même à
adam b3 ça ok et on n'avait pas prévenu
le coup de prague ici
il n'a pas pris d'option sans savait
parce qu'il y avait des problèmes sur
l'option b 5 on avait dit que c'était
pas possible il a joué cavalier f6 donc
là il les jusqu'au boutistes dans le
dynamisme et d'ailleurs ils payent pris
ces six ans parce que pressée si c'est
pas que la réponse des quatre cavaliers
prend ses six coop
du coup ça serait chaud donc il a joué
fou g5 sur cavaliers m6 pour garder la
pression meyerhoff de damas un qui a été
joué
et surclassé 3 on sait toujours pas on
n'a toujours pas repris le pion et les
grand temps de le faire donc il est
prévu b4
est sûr qu'à valider un il a enfin pu
reprenant des 5
le problème de tout ça c'est qu'il n'est
pas trop développées
avec avec baignoire ça c'est un peu
faible ça c'est un peu faible
attention fois je crois d'un milieu
rohff qui a bien compris quelle était
l'urgence de impose
donc vous prend cavaliers prend là je
pourrai un moment ramener le cavalier à
la fête il ya des pions quand même
qu'ils sont un peu faiblard stouff c'est
pas très coordonné cette position qui a
aidé cette ça se comprend tours c'est un
jeu mais un coup piquant sur le pion
sait si ça peut pas faire de mal à chis
pareils fou des deux ans vis-à-vis de la
dame
pour ces 8es dès maintenant f3 a été
joué
est ce que l'idée de f3 toof c'est
surprise f3 de jouer eux quatre
je pense quoi
c'est malin ça m'a l'air trop trop
wendel away et gamble et ben moi ce que
je voulais jouer comme quoi à ton
contact at on contacte souffre je ne
viens un peu fade à
eux croient f3c du fait que quatre
oies mais je me disais bien qu'il
fallait faire quelque chose avec mes
pièces ce que j'étais à tout moment d'un
point f3 vente ump quel point à 2 mais
bon je tire hoc ou cavaliers de nommer
même cavalier f2 alors le deun il fait
rien mon autre rival et l'a
peut-être ça j'ai toujours eu 5 à tout
moment
bon c'est vrai en fait
jamais
cela peut aller là
j'approuve donc f3 je pense que les
vielles de m'hamed et je voulais faire
plaisir à as tout faux proposant 4 m'a
dénigré mon idée vous avez vu mais au
début mais il s'est rangé quand même la
voix de la raison voilà il ya quand même
il ya quand même des arguments pour
jouer au centre comme ça ça fait au pire
sur prise d'empreintes directes et à
presque 4 petit rock est inquiète 4
[Musique]
alors j'ai le temps en fait mais mélissa
m de manger la dame en f3 août ou rouge
de quatre mois c'est sûr c'est sûr
en france
m6 à
la route ce qui se demande ce que ça
veut dire c'est quoi gamble s'est tiré
du poker en fait quand blé ou du jeu on
a du gaming enfin du jeu en casino
quand tu lis que gamble sais que je suis
un mec qui aime bien on va dire parier
ou genre prendre un risque un petit peu
débile comme tu vois bah quand jacques
gamblin sara qui aime bien attaquer et
faire plaisir
et je pensais parier comme au casino
quoi voilà prise de prise de risque
jouer avec prise de risque lingerie
gamble
sentait prêt à faire
c'est l'expression webdopoker non je
transporte je pense qu'une impression
dans le gaming
soit le poker mais c'est ses liens avec
du pari avec de l'argent qu'on va tout à
fait avec un enjeu
non mais
en tout cas
f3 on voit prime ananda il est déjà en
difficulté dans cette partie avec les
noirs autant ça se ressent un petit peu
et regarde il ya une petite blague
rapporte car yakine
sympa du pin s était pas loin de ton
prono un
t'imagines tu mets juste dit nul nul
dans un coup tu gagnes et facile le seul
vin pas mal pas mal souffre et jason tu
pouvais pas non plus ne pas passer un
petit peu tu vois c'est pire que tout
commence comment ce seul pouvait se
retourner contre toi ben c'est vrai ce
que ce à quoi tu avais la position mais
très bon alors deux coups quoi c'est
horrible quoi
c'est horrible horrible mais
dame ses sept tours 5 vous avez senti
mes propos ils sont venus avec tous
ces crèmes dommage je trouve à ankara
kinky qui pour moi la clé une position
avec un léger avantage la mire cavaliers
il a dit
oui en fait quand je cherchais j'ai vu
que la jetée à l'égalité alors que la
position de pareilles hyper agréable
donc quand j'essayais traduire entre
guillemets dans ma tête si lecavalier à
21 ans serait une grosse différence mais
sur d'un v6 je peux pas vraiment prendre
parce qu'en fait je fais pour le
problème sévère ici à tour ces quatre
fous des cette acception l'a donc du
coup elle joue tour b5 et maintenant ils
n'avaient pas envie de la dame rentre
non plus ce qui peut se comprendre et
fou 17 existera toujours dans les
positions les tours sont rentrés du coup
du coup c'est pas si facile et mon
cavalier il est muselée par le fait de
défendre des quatre parce que
l'adversaire a aussi la case c4 pour me
rendre la monnaie de de la pièce avec ma
tour qui est belle en b 5 mai la tour
adverse on sait qu'apple aurait été
vraiment très très forte
donc
c'est quand même
c'est quand même bien dommage voilà
on le voit
bon ok on peut on peut aller sur autre
chose c'était le petit clin d'oeil et on
a ça fait longtemps qu'on n'a pas été
voir
le petit plus le petit poulain et s'il a
fini par jouer fouet f2000 a pas joué au
même moment
alors on était là tout à leur faut trois
tours à des huit j'avais proposé fouet
f2 mais la préférée dames 1 c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment super sympa à
damas de karwan validé tour d un la
meilleure case pour la tour la dame est
forte en 1 puisque le plan c'est bien
fouet deux fous j'ai 3 pourquoi je dis
que le plan c'est ça parce que sur x f5
il a échangé il a joué tour d un
d'accord qu'il avait prévu et sur h ici
l'ajout et wave ii on avait dit qu'il
fallait appuyer sur cases noires c'est
en train d'être fait tous rêvent sept
fous j'ai trois dames c5 foued de dames
des six une sorte de propositions nul
implicite de jarden on n'a pas parlé de
la fin de proposer le pour gagner un
souffle ça cesse et c'est une autre une
autre fête aujourd'hui de jarden et du
coup bas caruana il a envie de gagner il
n'a pas trop le choix il a les pièces
blanches à une position hyper
intéressante
maintenant on voit pas trop pourquoi les
deux pièces seraient mieux dans cette
position en règle générale c'est bien
mais là on a le centre avec les noirs et
des tours active du coup c'est une
position complexe
ok moi c'était un petit tour d'horizon
j'aimerais bien aussi aller voir
les parties de
d'ici 2 de glee et si penco et ensuite
on retourne voir romanus advint souffre
parce que tu sais il y avait cette
position assez atypique quand même avec
l'appel préparation d'année giri qui
semble avoir porté ses fruits puisque
cavaliers ces cartes est maintenant très
jolie qu'elle h de moins et puis là on
peut peut-être valorise déception alors
on va regarder on s'était arrêté à ce
moment là sur dame prend d un tour prend
d un fou prend f2 et on n'avait pas vu
la suite de cette partie où il y aura
trois pions
contre la pièce ses positions assez
atypique
et il faut voir si ses pions pas c'est
qu'ils sont peu avancé on va réussir
petit à petit a créé la mêlée des all
blacks et avancer pas à pas pour les
valoriser donc frais fca très bons coups
des six penco je sors mon soutien qui
demandait à être sortis et j'attaque ces
six tours d2 encore un bon coup
évidemment puisque je tape le fouet f2
et sept tours va sortir fouet trois
normales fou prend trois tours prendre
trois
cavaliers de l'es4 d'accord cavaliers
ces quatre bons coups j'amène du monde à
la fête tous rêvent de et tours 8 et sur
ce il a joué tour à f
- f6 paraît logique parce qu'à tout
moment je pourrais mettre mon roi henri
vii
hockey position assez sympa position
assez sympa oui il ya encore des choses
à faire
décoter rien n'est clair
donc
bon ça avance un truc invités sont faut
avancer mais
pas grand chose par rapport à tout à
l'heure et la partie de ville 10
secondes des lieux s'est pas passé grand
chose par rapport à l'or il ya eu juste
la prison m6 ouais et là ça devient ça
devient dur à jouer avec toujours on
avait dix fois cavalier trois cavaliers
b3
taper les pions et la paire de fonds et
des cinq sur la faible et le
save our et c'est pas trop une position
pour grand des lieux ce qu'ils aiment
bien vraiment la baston générale sur
l'échiquier il n'a pas obtenu ce qu'il
voulait de l'ouverture avec baignoire
après il a
c'est un vote qui aime bien être actif
et quand elle a une position comme ça où
il faut qu'ils défendent très blesse et
ben généralement c'est pas vrai c'est
pas le meilleur pour
risque de passer une sale journée qu'un
grand des lieux dans cette danse est
parti puis qu'avec n'est qu'une noire je
dis bon ok
mais mes groupe d'élite
il a deux points et un dernier verre du
tournoi deux points sur sept c'est pas
lourd mais
ça peut faire deux points sur 8 à la fin
de la journée on verra bien mais
franchement on n'aimerait pas avoir la
position des noirs c'est une position de
résultats si vous voulez cygan des lieux
ça arrive à dire ça il fera peut-être
nul mais sait il va souffrir il est mal
autant ça fait pas mal de poids à
a su porter sur ses épaules ok du coup
on va retourner voir la partie fil rouge
c'est vrai qu'on s'attarde pas mal sur
magnus carlsen mais la partie promettait
déjà hyper sympa aie aie aie a pas eu
hyper déçu parce que franchement
mais tu vois ça pouvait être un cru le
coût proche est pour moi c'était un peu
le
bain car ça va laisser faire et je pense
que c'était un semi bluff de la part de
karen possible et
je pense qu'ils savaient contre qui
jouer et et que
s'enclenche
elle a dû considérer que c'est complexe
comprend achatt rappelle celle là qu'on
voulait faire sur le fou bekkat de
magnus on a regardé fo prend un chat qui
empêchait de roquet c'est un coup de
singles et parce que la tour est en face
de la dame
et c'était vraiment hyper rigolo et on a
passé un petit peu de temps à regarder
ça et je chante l'ennui des bijoux car
en scène aussi un donc j'ai l'impression
qu'il a choisi faut prendre ces trois un
peu tranquille et surtout prend ses
trois tours à b1 petite pression fouet
f6 dame de pas de prise de risque
non mais je pense que s'il avait joué un
double ou un tube la pointe s'est tordu
par tient
clairement mais méchant commencer par
son style
comme ça
et si c'est peut-être défendre 17 et
petit rôle
moi je me dis que ce choix ça annonce
quoi
pourquoi il a fait ça champion c'est
peut-être juste pour
bientôt jouer pour nul à
afgoye y fut celle ci les autres les
flammes et cinq à pied
tout processes je pense que la tour puis
barreteau qu'on 17 et tu m'en fous j'ai
un très bon qui peut être israël isolé
et il aussi passé donc à voir
comment ça commence à jouer mais ça n'a
pas encore ok ça
c'est quand même pas le piton sangla
père ne faut qu'on pense ici le retard
de développement qui n'est pas colossal
non plus faut quand même faire gaffe si
vous jouer des coudes imbécile peut y
avoir détourné un fo b ça qui est ça
peut vite vite vrillé genre de position
quand vous avez toujours votre rôle est
bien je je même sur des systèmes besson
pour enlever la part de flou noir et
après c'est dans une position peut-être
ans qu'ils ont rien fait on des six
tours des apôtres du rock food et 5 j'ai
quand même fou rire et a fait tomber 5
dans prendre bon je peux quand même
rentré en septième en fait j'ai eu peur
mais peut-être à tort un v6 fou b5
direct je me suis fou prend dame prend
et chaque dame 17
[Musique]
qui est peut-être jouable en ailleurs
mais peut-être dame prend tout
simplement ben non il y avoit prend
possible
après j'ai prêché rien c'est ce que je
me disais souffle tu vois je me suis dit
des six fours b5 fou prend d'emprunt
dame 17
donc dans les deux cas on a proposé deux
trucs un truc de cordes pour un peu la
même chose tous les deux
un fait si ya pas tant que ça en fait il
peut jouer b si je crois
ce que fois ci ce tour c'est cet
après ya peut être encore mieux un sur
dame de donc du coup
[Musique]
mais mais même cette position tu sais
quand tu proposes est fou c'est aussi ce
qui est vraiment pas mal fourbe et 5,6
joue petit rock tu nous parler de foot
france et 6
c'est un peu embêtant b prend je
regardais
même ça ça doit pas être si négatif que
ça mais c'est un peu dommage ça va c'est
plate pour la musique et noir alors que
bon l'attaquant même un deux contre un
sur le long terme donc tubes et si j'ai
des traits après tu as quand même le fou
et fcc contrôle à gaza après ton dans la
partie de ces rapports contre 45 qui
sait n'ont rien fait après le pont le
plus aura est passé avant ses avances à
avancer et puis le foot ou et donc du
coup peut-être d'être b6 boubée sacré
dames c'est ça tu
as maintenant 90 ans c'est mon idée
même si c'est par principe j'ai envie de
voguer cammas rapidement et de
cgt annonce en juin drame c'est celle
que je rends kokou suivant
ok donc fou aux quatre
sur cinq jours au caire x 4
là maintenant jobé si je pense
en fait c'était juste pour la blague du
temps réel général j'ai recréé leur
10ème by pas mais il faut pas pourquoi
ah oui et un coût qui est rigolo la
stouffs et
non ce tout petit je regardais qui a
aidé les quatre je n'ai pas trop vu qu'à
et des quatre sur fou prend pions prend
pour gêner le roi noir
mais ok c'est pas y'a pas une menace sur
petit rock ça va qu'est donc ça ok en
tout cas elle est quand même passé
c'est une partie qu'on assemble non
c'est hyper intéressante ça a été vrai
au début et là ça s'est vraiment calmé
pas une prise considérable de risque et
franchement on se marre moins que
précédemment à regarder cette partie
au début on attendait cette folie mais
finalement à bama médias off prime à
l'audace et c'est ce qu'on avait dit un
stuff
la partie qui peut être intéressante
c'est cipango giry
salut au lit tôt
eh
ouais du coup ton petit prague à mon
avis on peut retourner un petit peu le
voir voilà
et il ya eu
quel génie
bas sa santé et je sens pas du tout le
petit prague se sortir de cette position
apparemment s'est aggravée en envoie la
jauge qui est terrible et du coup l'idée
de du f3 de mamediarov alors prague à
fait car il y avait 6 il n'a pas voulu
prendre mais il s'est pris cavaliers f2
et surprise de 4 dans nos pires
conditions encore kiev 6 kms 6 et petit
rock
et là on a une poubelle parce que même
si un pion info pions plus ici bon on va
leur perdre prochainement et on voit que
le cas et d un qui est la pire pièces
des blancs ça c'est assez intéressant
baïla
il a de beaux jours devant lui et quand
il va arriver en 3 il va menacer
énormément de choses
prague risque de perdre pas mal de temps
en plus dans cette position il n'a pas
encore aucun en plus
c'est pas une partie top top en tout cas
ce qu'il a il est mal au bout de peu de
coups en fait c'est ça qui est un peu
embêtant
ouais
c'est pas une belle journée
et mamediarov qui
doit être bien content
actuellement c'est rare d'être aussi
bien aussi vite
ok
là je sais pas ce qui va jouer prague et
on voit pas trop l'aider je pense en le
regardant il est il est dominé
une partie qui
m'intéresse un petit peu quand même
c'est la partie alors double of bas il
se passe rien c'est presque fini voilà
on va bientôt avoir la nul entre
nous bouffer
chez nous dans la balance je regarde un
match où on ces deux joueurs qui font ce
spectacle généralement un public
centralise il va quand même piqué duda
le pion à 4 il mange le pire mais
ouais je suis un peu étonné qu'il ait
réussi ce petit tour de force puisqu'il
y avait il y avait vraiment rien c'est
les gérants de mal débrouillé quand même
quoi il a tout fait pour avoir cette
position
bon ok
bon il va réussi à faire annuler cette
position avec l'option de moi
mais quand même c'est un petit peu et
est ce que tu penses que pas le moment
de faire notre deuxième pub allez on va
revenir plus fort allez pas de souci
donc les fameuses six minutes de pub par
heure et du coup après
son premier gros tournoi en présentiel
comme ça avec les avec le top niveau
ouais c'est pour ça c'est pour ça que
c'est
important ce côté là de créer
l'expérience et si pendant la pub vous
savez pas quoi faire n'hésitez pas à
aller voir la chaîne de touffes voilà et
vous aussi avoir la chaîne près volution
échec on est souvent live donc n'hésitez
pas à venir nous voir ça me fera grand
plaisir et comme ça vous allez découvrir
les temps qu'on propose de stream chaque
semaine ça nous fera un grand plaisir en
tout cas et on vous dit ben bonne bonne
pub à tous t as qu on dit dans ces cas
là stouff
allez on vous envoie la pub et on vous
dit
tout de suite
[Musique]
oh
pourtant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et on est de retour avec du beauf à
l'écran
voilà qui va avoir il va dur à faire un
avenir cette cette finale avec un point
de moins que le beurre contre 12 heures
avec avec 4 contre 5 comme ça avec un
option passer adel
pour être maître avec toi je n'ai jamais
rien compris
il ya il ya un risque
que la tour aille jusqu'aux un
jeu évidemment la tour à 8 ce serait
mieux à 8 on préfère la tour derrière
sous le pion de côté
la moins bonne configuration c'est la
configuration configuration actuelle
pour pour duda c'est à dire que ça
tourne mal et obligés de rester à la
défense de son pion qui va se faire
attaquer
cette tour là va se mettre derrière
vraisemblablement d'ailleurs on a 500
total se mettront à 5
il a choisi tours 5e pour limiter les
actions des noirs sur cet endroit
il va mettre sa tour en a cinq et avec
les noirs on va avoir la position tout
un
pion à 3 si on met le pion à deux déjà
sera terminée
parce que notre tour et notre pions sont
coincés et même si on arrivait à amener
le roy on se prend plein d'échec et à
chaque fois dès que mon roi veut aller
proche de la tour adverse
ben on se remet derrière on a
envoyé dans la configuration tour à tour
à cinq qui ont à deux tours 1 et on peut
pas s'en défaire de cette configuration
où la tour vient nous mettre des coups
des chèques ensuite à se remet derrière
le pion à quoi c'est donc là la
configuration qui pourrait arriver c'est
toi un pion à 3 pour réussir à amener
le roi jusqu'en b2 et sur un coup des
chèques faits rois de la problématique
stéphane c'est que si je mets mon rang à
deux blocs moi même mon pions et pendant
ce temps là la tour peut aller sur les
pions noirs et là ça peut être ça peut
être la galère
ça peut vraiment de la galère
donc il ya peu de chances que ça passe
normalement il faudrait plus swing à ce
niveau là les joueurs m'ont connaissent
bien leur finale lesbiennes donc il est
fort probable qu'ils arrivent à se
défendre mais j'ai pas davantage des bas
salaires
mais bon je suis ici mais il s'est
compliqué la vie est déjà très
clairement pour rien
bon là on va attendre un petit peu que
ça se décante et on reviendra et la
partie qu'il l'a pu décompter c'est la
partie de ton poulain je crois
sauf si on y retourne avec un prague qui
en difficulté
qui vient de proposer à mamediarov les
changes les dames
comment on continuerait ça
on peut laisser prendre en b3 c'est pas
un problème
on peut aussi
ciment jambes et 3 après apprendre et 3g
quand même la bonne à pomas tour
contrôle des cases
contre les quinze rieschick y est là
mais ok je peux j'ai aussi les suites
concrètes de faire d'un prend 1,4 pour
faire qu'elles provoquaient cavaliers
prend 1,4 et faire pourquoi pas du des
5e 5 on a plein de
plein d'idées assez agressive
pour faire mal
mais bon on a pu en a sans doute pas
besoin de ça c'est vrai que
là guy lagarde et les dames et
maintenant
voyez vous m
c'est très dur quand
il avait six coups c'est ça qu'il faut
bien dire à vagues les blancs tout est
et tout est maintenant
tout est maintenant bon avec les pièces
qui sont
sont mal positionné puisque si les noirs
peuvent prendre un pion surtout ils
pourront pas prendre le deuxième à cause
de tour et b1
donc c'est trop dur c'est trop dur
on le voit bien est l'option à 7 en
l'air
donc d'un point à 2 tours à payer le
pion à 7 qui meurent encore je suis même
pas obligés de s a enfin tout et tout
est bon je vais toujours avoir ce
cavalier f5 qui peut arriver les cinq
5 cavaliers 4 je bouffe f3 cavaliers f5
on sait pas où mettre son roi l'abri
avec les noirs mais la position est très
très difficile du coup
ça devait mal se passer prochainement
pour prague banda
et du coup alors et si penco cas ce que
ça donne cette partie atypique
voilà juste un petit tour d'horizon
après on ira voir magnus ans a fermement
qu'on a pas été voir ouais j'ai bien
aimé ce qu'a fait
cette position très m'intéresse stéphane
parce que
je trouve que c'est un peu dur pour pour
les blancs
mais peut-être là un petit tour ou deux
est ce que c est ce que ça arrange les
blancs mais c'est une question
est ce qu'on échange une tour et pas la
deuxième
moi j'ai envie de dire que les mois on
devrait garder les pièces très mal et
tours sont mieux poster géant pression
des tours 7
ofi l'aqsiq je défends la future menace
qui est tour 17 des blancs et jusqu'à
maintenant moi j'aime leur position moi
je meilleur chaque pièce et puisque
attend de voir un peu mais je pense pas
que vraiment un jeu pour le galsi
moi j'ai envie de le faire pousser mes
pions en tout cas
bon pour leur donner la valeur
j'aimerais bien avoir mon trio de pions
l'a déjà et puis commencé à casser les
cases du cavalier
treize fois l'attention parce que
vos pions tant qu'ils sont liés et côte
à côte ils contrôlent toutes les cases
mais d'un coup ça peut être vraiment ça
peut être vraiment beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus difficile
donc fait attention
quand vous poussez vos pions ne pas
laisser trop lecavalier bloc où je perds
un pion faire attention fois ce que je
veux dire par là c'est qu'il faut les
avancées de manière unie ça c'est hyper
important
c'est même là la base pourquoi avoir
fait attention sur g6 là y'a pas tour
premier signe après apprend qu'elle est
atteinte matour est protégé mais c'est
le genre de chose dont il faut se méfier
il peut y avoir des petites petites
bricoles
manqué savait que du bluff salut à toi
bienvenus
ça se gavent sauvegarde et on va mettre
la partie chant plan de quarante scène
tu nous disais je trouve que enfin tu me
disais que tu allais avoir un petit pari
à me proposer
mais j'attends ça avec impatience
pascal a du coup en terme de paris
machacka parier sur un joueur sur un
petit boulot pour l'instant on retrouve
bien pour moi j'ai parié pour
sur le petit prague
et tacle à parier sur ventes forest qui
est le vainqueur de l'ès
tu l'a rappelé quand tu l'a rappelé
j'avais oublié en fait un tout va
vraiment au chaud lui cherche t-elle dit
j'avais vraiment oublié parce que saint
thomas
en plus j'ai non j'ai pas pensé et je me
suis dit de toute façon je compte qu'on
t'a choisi prague n'a choisi un outsider
enfin voir le plus gros size outsider à
mon sens donc c'est un pari risqué donc
je t'aurais accepter même que je prenne
ma news de toute façon acquis ont été un
pari beaucoup plus sûres et du coup je
me suis qui je vais prendre et en fait
y'a pas tant que ça mais il n'y a pas de
petit joueur fait un petit joueur dès le
6 si j'avais dû prendre un risque
d'ailleurs en fait première personne à
laquelle j'ai pensé c'était grand delius
et je me suis où c'est vraiment loose
grand des lieux non à l'or qui je peux
prendre je veux aussi vendre forrest
plus beaucoup plus sûr quand même mais
c'est le maigre le mois sur après grande
d'hélios est en fait voilà passé c'est
plus logique quoi je veux bien prendre
des risques mais des risques mesurés je
peux parler grand delius ce que c'est
plus c'est plus un espoir c'est un
joueur du du top niveau mondial mais pas
pour faire il a de la chance d'être dans
ce tournoi là parce qu'il ya d'autres
prétendants qui pour elle à sa place un
vraiment événement en termes d'âgés et
de et de niveau
du cou le bail que je vais te proposer
ses bons atouts supplémentaires on va
toujours ajouter à tout cela
en cours en quoi les plus sains voilà
tout ce qui est en cours et si tu veux
on peu après après la ronde bien entendu
chacun de notre côté eh ben on se marre
qu un
un classement
l'argent définitif après la ronde après
l'as rome 13 donc bon moi par exemple
les quatorze toiles
voilà moi je peux qu arsène va gagner
pommier et après le deuxième cas je te
voilà on va mettre un petit peu et à
chaque place exacte qu'on trouve est
bien souvent un petit sable n'obtient
donc sachant que les départage bon
imaginons ils sont trois à quatre points
enfin ou 3 1 ou 2 points et ben ils sont
pas à la bonne place s'est perdu voilà
je comprends bien chouette c'est le tout
pile ou rien le tout pile ou rien à la
gérante des lieux je le mets par exemple
dernier s'il finit très très 13e excès
prague le dernier jeu marque aucun point
quoi même s'ils sont ex-aequo
exemple les bourses tout faux pas
c'est le oui oui donc il faut soit
envoyé assez vite face à envoyer assez
vite pour que
la garde
ça prend ça promet faut pas faire un
faux pas faire de boulettes teinte a
bien bien bien pensée ton plan là je
suis père inquiet stouff à y faire face
je crois que t'as pas dû t'as pas dû
dormir beaucoup cette nuit pour mettre
en place ce plan infaillible est
terrible
on a eu le goût
on sait comment ça se passe c'est un
plan infaillible et finalement ça
déconne complet sur la dernière ronde
jusqu'à la dernière ronde ça tiens t'as
tout bon et après la dernière ronde
résultat improbable et c'est perdu
donc ouais cette position est ce que est
ce que c'est dur ou pas pour magnus
est-ce que c'est dur
regarde on s'était arrêté après dames 2
et il a joué le fameux tour c'est cette
je touche pas à ma structure depuis on a
envoyé que les joueurs sont très
conservateurs dans les positions de jeu
de construction
il n'aime pas touché leurs pions s'il
avait touché en jambes et 6,6 laisser
des cases des trous
là et il se laisse le choix
d'avancer comme ils le souhaitent ses
pions a et b dans le futur pour aller
créer le pion passé de 4 a été jouée
pour valoriser ce seul pion au centre
avec les idées de casser le fouet f6 qui
finalement dominer complètement le
cavalier f3 petit rock que 5 et magnus a
simplement amener le foin set
c'était quoi l'histoire
petit adam 4 avec le pion achète le pion
bessette et surfe où on sait s'il n'a
pas joué d'avocate parce qu'en fait d'un
match peut jouer bas g6 et si je prends
baies sata fous ces six
même peut-être fou f5 aussi
donc enfin de là il ya des problèmes
donc d'arcade ne gagnez rien donc il a
préféré l'amélioration du cavalier avec
cavaliers des cats
et les noirs on a peur de fou mais c'est
une petite paire de fou on voit pour
l'instant les fous sont pas aussi beau
que
les pièces les pièces blanches il ya
toujours du dam katki et qui est présent
avec cette menace là donc magnus doit
pas avoir mille coups à disposition
il faut anticiper ce 2e cat en tout cas
très clairement
donc qu'est-ce qu'on joue aux to five et
noir il faut trouver le coup de magnus
je prends un petit outil de prise de
notes stouff mes pronos pour pas oublier
de les faire
ok mais alors je trouve tes coincé dans
la position de manu j'ai l'impression
que tu préfère prendre
prendre les blu ray ce qu'on pourrait
pas jouer le petit coup dams et 8
je me dis que ça déforme pions bessette
ça me permet de poster ma tout au long
des huit à n'importe quel moment
g6
et après ça m'évite de prendre à eux si
c'est aussi un moment et après je peux
soit mettre ma tour en 8 ou en des huit
faire fouette fric fou g7 ça ressemble
très bien ce que fait magnus des fois je
me dis que je propose dams et 8 après je
joue comme magnus quoi tu vois non mais
souvent il réussit klein pas mal c'est
ses pièces comme cela est
elle se sent pas impossible après les
blancs ils font nul peut être facilement
maintenant dans ses positions là et mes
cinq choses comme ça
mais je le verrais bien faire des
grandes manoeuvres pour se remettre bien
et pas du tout pas du tout il n'a pas
l'air
bon il vous il veut gagner toutes ces
parties donc
il est exigeant quoi et la s'attend
quand même assez facilement vers la
nulle je pense parce qu'à des cavaliers
b5 des cavaliers f 5,6 j'échange le fou
il y aura de bonnes chances de nuls quoi
salut tortue il était petit zinc oui
j'ai tout lu je l'avais vu le couvent
est magique
hello tout ce qui arrive en cours
mais oui c'est pas
c'est sûr que pour magnus maintenant
s'attendaient peut-être à une partie
plus débridé il avait pris une prise de
risque dans le début quand même et
finalement elle s'avère seulement à
moitié payante avec une partie à
léquilibre ici
il sent que ça va bientôt qu'elle a il
faut que je trouve un coup quand même
avec un
règle et blanc
je sais pas trop m
ce cavale est-ce que j'ai besoin de
jouer dans ce cas tout non
non mais en tout cas il se passe moins
de choses dans cette position que qu'on
a l'habitude de le voir dans les parties
de
de magnus je sais pas si tu as vu
caruana
vent de forrest nul stouff
qu'avant de forest
merci j c'est tout
oui alors on peut aller vite fait voir
pourquoi nul ouais il a refusé une fois
hull caruana mais il n'a pas trouvé la
clé dans sa dans sa position tout petit
en passant
de préparation mais c'est ça
moi j'irai voir autant depuis le début
j'étais tu vois sur sur dame de même
leur dit préférer
préférez un petit peu la position de
devant de forest il proposait dans cette
position de continuer le débat avec dams
et 4
ce qui n'était pas un coup facile à
jouer d'ailleurs ça pas été trouvé
juste pour voir ouais bon tout peut se
passer encore
ouais c'était étaient extrêmement
extrêmement compliqué se basant sur le
fait qu'il ya une menace de cadre à tout
moment mais bon ça peut aussi la perte
d'âme d'être dame prend puis on prend
fou g3e quatre voiliers ont fait des
trous quand un peu partout c'était pas
si sûr non plus et on peut comprendre
qu'ils soient pas risqué à faire un
faire cela
il faudra vérifier cette partie elle
était vraiment intéressante un stuff
simplement le met à l'idée je l'avais
déjà vu un rex à un deux pièces pour la
tour on dit souvent que c'est pas bon et
regardez là il a réussi à le faire dans
de bonnes conditions puisque il
reprenait au centre il a eu cette
position il n'a pas eu trop de problèmes
pour la gérer
c'est décevant pour qu'à roanne avec les
pièces les pièces blanches et
et du coup bon bah c'est une belle
chance de gâcher après ça
sa victoire sa victoire convaincante
d'hier il n'est pas assez stable dans ce
tournoi ça dépend des parties ça peut
être tout bon ou tout mauvais
alors juste pour te dire là je tapais
champion des jeux aussi c'est donc à le
fameux et puis s'il avait joué
s'il avait je donne ces huit stouff il
serait pas pris ça
dur
mais qu'est ce qu'ils font pourquoi dame
se vident n'avait pas été joué non mais
ça sentait que c'était un des thèmes de
la position en plus
bon 6
ça reste quand même sans doute ah oui
faire attention si on veut s'amuser avec
cette simplification la tension
retourner contre nous parce que il ya
peu mangé le fou 17 bien sûr tout aussi
faire de cette fourchette voilà donc fou
prend 1,6 bon là c'est en train de
de se calmer
[Musique]
voilà là on est en train de voir la
séquence
on voit que faut pas y avoir beaucoup de
surprises
mais possiblement puisque magnus n'est
pas content il est très très exigeant
dans ce tournoi à manu s'il veut faire
le score max et
là on sent qu'il n'est pas pas satisfait
de sa pause
on peut imaginer qu'il va y avoir
qui vous allez avoir un prochain
match nul ouais je vois bien arriver se
trouve alors comment on continue ça avec
avec les blancs ont fait d'un promu 6
c'est logique
où on garde pour plus tard on n'a pas
non plus un facile dames 4
je pourrai manger
oui oui oui ça semble logique
en fait ce qui se passe pour même sûr
même si rouages fuite
la problématique c'est que sur 24 celle
ci défend depuis on achète on peut pas
facilement prendre en baisse puisqu'on a
toujours fous des trois surveillée qui
est en l'air
donc ça va ça va maintenant
et ça va se calmer très prochainement
voir infra grandes chances de nuls
aggravée par le le côté foot couleurs
opposées dans cette position il n'y a
pas de pions passé
je pense pas qu'il y ait de roy hyper
faible parce que même si le roi de
magnus est un peu plus faible
d'apparence on voit que quand on suit
puis avec g6 et le fou qui vient sur la
diagonale moi je ne crains pas grand
chose non plus ça va être très dur de
faire h4h inquiet de réussir à ouvrir
les cases blanches sur ce roi donc il ya
bien eu dans mais comme ci seront
ensuite tu dis pardon tout fait ce que
moi
exactement et pion f2 c'est un peu trop
light nous on va pouvoir faire ou à agen
f3 irait ou alors je fais je fais j'ai
trois je vais réussir à jour où un chef
quatre jeux mais il faut aussi il ya
plusieurs manières de sauver les rois et
on dit que dans l'hérault qu'oppose dans
les footeux couleurs opposées pardon
c'est vraiment le facteur du roi qui
pourrait être déterminant pour inverser
cette tendance du match nul danser dans
ses positions
salut à toi mot mines
ouais du coup là on peut s'attendre
quand même a
vraisemblablement un match nul quoi la
partie perd un petit peu de son intérêt
on voit on va revenir plus tard et c'est
intéressant parce que la partie de
pragma médias évoluent
rapidement quand même je dirais
traque s'est accroché au fait de vouloir
échanger dame stouff on s'est arrêté là
tout à l'heure à pression était très
difficile un pion de plus pour prague
mais il est là il va se faire croquer à
terme
du coup dans cette dans cette situation
il ya eu d'un bep 5dans prend puis on
prend
et maintenant on peut faire le jeu tout
reprend ses huit pour mettre mal le
cavalier noir ans et 8e 5 pareil pour
gagner de l'espace sur le cavalier qui
arrivait en 17 cavaliers f5 nous pour
améliorer nos pièces et sur g6 on peut
imaginer qu'ils avaient
prévu de prendre et il prendra en b
cathy mettra cavaliers en quatre des six
tours premier 3 ça va faire un pion de
plus et que des pièces hyper jolie pour
mamediarov
donc là c'est grosse déception pour
prague lambda qui a beau jouer vite mais
il se démonte pas en face
moi je pense que là non plus c'est pas
forcément hyper intéressant de
s'attarder et ça fait un moment qu'on
n'a pas vu
visite du boeuf et apprendre est allé
voir le jeune français marc-andré maori
d'y aller
alors la partie
entre vidic est grande et luce et ben ça
devient un peu plus illisibles quand
s'est produit cette histoire
on s'est arrêté là
tout était simple entre guillemets on
disait que roy grand roque cavaliers b3
prises des 4 etc il y à bien gros rock
tour 8 a été joué et cavaliers b3 un peu
comme on voulait
et ce qui aurait fallu d'abord faire
[ __ ] en g7 dans cette situation ce qu'
il ya eu qu'un voilier e6
et du coup le pion des cats est tenue
tous les deux le tac le titre kbc sept
fous j'ai deux cavaliers 7
et la f5 a été jouée par par me dit
qu'ils pouvaient déjà sans doute prendre
prendre des quatre pions pro f 5 et
c'est marrant à la conception de vie dit
qu'ils avaient une position très
avantageuse souvent quand vous êtes
quand vous avez davantage ce qu'on dit
c'est qui vous êtes assez conservateur
et construire tranquillement en essayant
de garder de garder par dont le
caractère de la position
mais il n'en a rien été vice il a envoyé
une grosse brique avec cinq insurgés
prend fbi mme toure f1
donc je prends un f5 et de tuer tous
élus étaient d'abord la colonne g et sur
f projet 4
c'est possible ou âgées d'abord moi en
tout cas il veut jouer sur le roi le roi
faible mais à plus les dames donc la
prise de risque est quand même
importante alors on va voir f franges et
qu'est-ce que tu jouerais stouff
jour regarde joue tout reprend m6
parce que cette reprise f6 prise prisa
choix fut prend vous prendrez 5
encore mieux je crois
mais prises des 5 c à maintenon direct
n'a pas sûr on va voir priver car de
regarder ce qu'on est en train de
regarder on sait on s'amuse un petit peu
tout reprend un f6 est la leur c'est de
laisser ce curage 3 parce qu'on voit les
petites méchancetés donc au début
j'avais vu comme tout fou prend h3
qui est le couteau en temps régulier
tour g1 mais est ce que est ce qu'on
peut se permettre
j'ai voulu encore plus mais peut-être
peut-être que c'est pas parce que c'est
pas ok file aussi si on peut prendre h
30 être qu'on veut prendre en d5
fou proches 3 est en fait prises des 5
c'est que nul
ne le forcez cavaliers prendrait cinq
tour g1 je pensais mater ça me donnait
une idée de maths lointain à court terme
mais je me suis ça se doit mater en fait
après avoir fui de marrant je m'attaque
pas
dommage tu es beau
fou gc à 3 gbit nul
est fou prend h3 je crois que c'est un
peu pareil stouff caylar bien
fou prend
tour g13 schmitt fou j'ai cet endroit g8
comment on continue ça est ce qu'on peut
continuer
en fait si vous voulez on n'est pas loin
du mat quand même la dent de la honte de
proposer par stouff puisqu'il peut y
avoir des
pourquoi pas toi f3 d'ailleurs
menace matt menace le fou menace faut
cinq gagnants cavale à ya encore donc
faux faux prend 1,3 et prix fort puisque
tu peux encore jouer
mais j'étais toujours aussi sa meilleure
qui es tu as mangé es tu vas manger h3g
sa défense
parce qu'il faut que je pars le matin
même à mes jeux 6 h 5
oui je pense à mes yeux mais la facture
est dans les courants d'air quoi la
tranche 3 en mai pour six tours si je
peux jouer fois f6 intermezzo
1.637 et maintenant fou aux cinq
qui est roi
peut-être peut-être et puis je compte
bien placé les tours
il ya incroyable il me les faits tous en
grèce c'est chaud hein c'est dur ça il
ya du monde en l'air ok c'est sympa et
c'est en fait sa
une ce soit super mal en fait cette
position
dont j'ai aussi sur jaj 3 j'ai pensé
aussi j'ai eu peur du retour j'ai un
soja h 3 h de marche pas pour des verts
fou des cinq matches avec moi je suis
touché on attend tout revient ici sur
une finale j 3
h de ce match
chaque projet est sympa aussi ce qui est
proposé bravo bravo hazen tour g1 nice
avait en fait c'est la même que tu as
l'air c'est simple oui je penche pour la
tour tu manges nuls encore mai
donc c'est sympa
mais ça marche pas en fait on voit que
le plus précis passé et ça quand même
donc un certain style quand même un
secours aux visites parce que on voit
que j'éprouve 5 c'est foutu sur notre
positionnement
fg cat c'est hyper dur de jouer à quatre
dans cette position avec tours f6 comme
on vient de le voir à moins que dans
cette position il ya un coup miracle
mais il n'a pas l'air
donc il peut pas
donc c'est hyper classe qu'il a joué
vous voyez un normalement on doit les
conservateurs mais là c'est un joueur à
27,30 visite qui fait un gros tournoi
quand même dans l'ensemble même si hier
il est tombé sur un vent de forrest des
grands jours
non franchement c'est beau hein la
conception trouve ça c'est ce qu'on fait
en blitz en totale maîtrise parce que
nous on adore il est
nommé là là en fait ça presque bien
tourné dans un certain sens pour pour en
des lieux c'est parce que c'est
typiquement les positions de créa et
mais le problème c'est croyait 7 je me
disais que c'était sympa mais il ya
quand même j'ai pris un f5 je croise le
roi voilà donc ça a été jouée à tempo
par visite et maintenant c'est quoi
l'idée de de grandes hélices parce que
si on pouvait se libérer avec ça
pourquoi pas mais le problème sur
canalsat yaka et d4 et je tiens tout de
la pause
le seul truc c'est que je ne prends pas
ça parce que j'ai toujours fait preuve
cinq peut-être bon ça va être
mais on s'est quand même dur
ça ça au vu de
nos jour d'hui le petit protégé de
stouff c'est pas loin d'être finie
nature mais ça reste entre nous darko un
petit secret que je te dis là voilà
les petits secrets les petits secrets
non mais c'est vrai que c'est déjà dur
hein qu'est ce que ça joue bien à quoi
après il n'ya tueur c'est comme un coup
c'est quoi
vraiment pour toi en fait il ya il ya
deux miniatures ya la miniature moins de
quinze coups la miniature minc ou quoi
là on a quand même
je suis d'accord mais en fait pour le
haut niveau se retrouver voilà en fait
ils continuent mais c'est déjà des
guillemins c'est pas et c'est un petit
jeune prague londres a bien meilleure
que nous donc c'est tout c'est
proportionnel convient pas de souci il
joue mammadyarov qui c'est le meilleur
joueur de ma catégorie d'âge du coup je
me rends compte il a été peut-être
quintuple champion du monde dans la
catégorie au moins
du coup c'est un monstre donc c'est très
très difficile mais cela dit la position
qu'il a obtenu la très très vite déjà
aussi en garde la position avant le 15e
la 14e avec f3 c'était déjà très dur et
cette position ne voulais vraiment pas
après eux quatre là c'était on est au
16e franchement on va regarder sa
position avant le 20e ces dégâts
donc c'est pour ça que celle là était
dur comme parti
après darko les joueurs sont tellement
bien préparé des deux côtés qu'il est
rare que sa sombre avant les 20 premiers
coups quoi c'est donc
moins de quinze coups signature qu'on va
qualifier d'extrême et moins de vingt
coups c'est déjà une miniature pour ce
niveau là en tout cas
j'ai joué en fait comme j'ai fait 2 2
chemin du monde jeune oui j'ai joué des
joueurs forts
thomas chef qui pour ceux qui
connaissent ils et 27,50 ou hangars où
j'ai joué en ruine l'ami smits telle
vague hunt ou les hollandais qui sont
devenus qui sont devenus forts mais
parce que j'ai fait le choix du monde je
vais quelques azéri aussi là bas
mammadov bon c'est si vous faites le
choix du monde en jeunes généralement
vous jouer des mecs qu'ils viennent tous
grands maîtres c'est pour ça que c'est
une anomalie que ce soit pas grand
maître stouff
ya peut-être une explication derrière
mais oui oui aller et puis sinon ce qui
est génial pour
en tant que français c'est de jouer le
top le top 16 ou top 12 et là vous jouez
d'efforts joueurs j'ai joué maxime
vachier lagrave deux fois dans l'est
dans les très forts tournoi français
aussi on peut jouer jouer porticcio j'ai
joué etienne bacrot laurent frayssinet
aussi au top au top 12 qui ont fait le
tome 12 vous voudriez vous jouez tous
les monstres en fait c'est ça qui
excellait un excellent
obama évite yougov quand j'avais le
championnat du monde a du championnat
d'europe adultes voilà c'est tout l'été
en fête plus vous fait d'être ou non à
force ça dépend des choix des joueurs il
ya des joueurs qui préfèrent faire des
tournois pour faire des petits prime de
tournoi moi je préfère faire des
tournois fort que je ne peux pas gagner
et où je me prend des bonnes raclées
avec les top players mais déjà les jouer
contre eux est temps entend tirer une
petite draw faire un faire un gros match
bas c'est hyper intéressant donc c'est
la bonne philosophie et je rappelle que
j'étais très déçu parce que pour la
première fois lorsqu'il ya eu le premier
confinement donc c'était il ya enfin le
seul confinement ont d'ailleurs quand il
ya une première vague je devais partir à
reykjavik souffert le tournoi de
reykjavik et s'acheter bien vert parce
que là encore c'était un tournoi andy
ronde si je dis pas de bêtise ça
promettait en cas de bons tours 1-2 ma
part de pouvoir jouer des gros joueurs
yaghi qui l'a déjà fait par exemple ce
tournoi de reykjavik bref on retrouve on
retrouve des joueurs forts quoi nettoie
souffre c'est quoi ta meilleure perf
meilleur père en tant que genre le plus
gros gain pourrait plus gros gain mon
plus gros lots que j'ai battu en partie
lente yes
bah c'était à c'était porte toujours une
26 dont il nous a parlé hier t1 id one
ce qu ils avaient ils avaient quasiment
l'avait 2590 comme ça et après j'ai
battu plusieurs joueurs à 25 60 50 mais
j'avais plus de 26 c'est quand même
hyper fort ainsi voilà
après moi j'ai un style qui est qui a
acquis assez généralement toi j'aime
bien attaquer j'aime bien moi du coup ça
me va c'est parce que quand à lui le roi
même d'argent fort si tu du situe
vraiment lui met une pression dingue tu
peux
en fait par exemple moi j'ai des potes
bon qui ont bien plus de l'autre max
d'un meilleur que moi qui ont jamais
fait performant à plus de 2005
parce qu'en fait
barak sont très solides ils perdent pas
beaucoup par contre ils gagnent pas
beaucoup non plus alors que moi je perds
beaucoup plus que je peux faire des
perfs du rose parce que bunge et
je comprends bien cela je vois tout à
fait ce que tu lis pas ce que
j'ai maintenant 24,50 bien stable à mon
niveau mais je fais beaucoup moins deux
perfs qu'avant c'est ça qui est assez
drôle quoi maintenant que je suis s'est
amusé à 24,50 ça y est je fais plus de
perfs alors que quand je t'ai 24,00 je
faisais vraiment pas mal de deux grosses
perfs voilà donc c'est pas facile
d'avoir les deux le style stable et de
temps en temps des victoires éclatantes
n'annonçait du ces du rhin ce côté là
on fait faux et il faut les deux faux
les deux pour pour pour avancer et c'est
de plus en plus dur mais c'est vrai
qu'il ya un gros gap à 26,1 j'ai déjà
parlé de ça des des grands maîtres qui
ne mériteraient d'avoir une étoile entre
guillemets à partir de 26
pour dire grand match et pas de première
catégorie en tout cas c'est vrai qu'il
ya une différence c'est vrai que des 26
les battre c'est que l'argent n'est pas
battu beaucoup parce que c'est un agneau
du amitiés l'autre dur un grand maître à
2500 bien sûr ça reste très fort pour
mettre à 2500 mais bon enfin un toit et
- la gamme battu pas mal chacun mais
mais c'est vrai que quand m à 2006 c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment un autre niveau
et pour moi c'est plutôt le on va dire
le niveau grande professionnelle en 2010
même en france en dessous de 2006 en
tant que joueur prêté m du mal à vivre
je pense donc pour moi je vois vraiment
le niveau professionnel en tant que
joueur d'échecs à plus de
je dirais je trouve que c'est des
joueurs vraiment très complet
généralement
un bon savoir théorique différents selon
les cas il ya les purs bosseur théorique
connaissent beaucoup de choses ou
d'autres qui font moins de théorie mais
qui connaissent très bien leur
répertoire donc en fait dans un sens et
dans l'autre c'est hyper compliqué on a
un peu moins de travail dans un cas le
matin mais on va aller quand même dans
le jardin de l'adversaire et après bas
ils ont des facilités calculatoire un
jeu de construction propre et après
selon les cas bien sûr c'est plus ou
moins prononcés sur chaque critère mai
mais c'est vrai que généralement c'est
dur de dur de dur à partir de 2 26 en
fait c'est bien que ça se passe bien
dans dans l'ouverture déjà
c'est une grosse aide moi tous les
résultats que j'ai fait contre les 26
les ouvertures sont se sont bien passées
et c'est encore pire contre les 27
c'est c'est clair que il faut que
l'ouverture se passe très très bien
c'est hyper important si les mecs
commence à avoir l'avantagé ils vont
vous faire du mal
ouais j'avais joué contre
entre eux alors qu'on dit s'appeler
sepa couvre bof c'était
c'est pas impossible que ce soit korobov
non c'était pas korobov
copains craignant la
réponse est oui
alex est allé voir à chaque conte et
franchement vous avez donné comme ça
qu'ils jouent pour grasse en équipant en
un adulte vous avez fait venir trois
2007 3 2007 en un an tu es assez content
et je vais jouer je crois que le genre
est chez nous et j'avais pris l'avantagé
avec les noirs il ya crime au rouge
quand aussi qui tient des bons de
l'équipe avec rennes qu il avait cours
au boeuf
et j'en avais joué 1 et j'avais un
avantage dans l'ouverture avec les
droits en juin benko hk plus
mais c'était un plus de on voyait pas
trop on voit que c'est bien mais bon
c'était difficile à jouer quelques mois
après j'ai perdu
et je suis un ce match cela ce match
c'est samir vaincre jeu pour mon équipe
qui avait qui avait accroché
donc je sais plus indé un d eux
craignent un il avait failli faire nul
duré six heures
c'est terrible parce que les mecs bien
sûr quand je sais que j'ai jouer des
mecs comme vache la grave tout ça si
vous faites la partie de votre vie
contre eux même si ces gars et tout ça à
la fin mais qui a encore du jeu ils vont
juste vous tester un donc faudra pas
craquer ce qui m'est déjà arrivé contre
des top players moi j'ai faim tout les
26-27 que j'ai plus joué en finale j'ai
pas la technique nécessaire ça me coûte
du temps et des fois c'est le gros
craquage dans la finale qui est
également le joueur des pelles est
assurée facilement ben moi j'ai pas ces
prérequis là et c'est vrai qu'un peu
fatigué peut-être de toute la partie est
due à un manque de technique
régulièrement contre les grands maîtres
après avoir fait des jolies parties je
me suis fait avoir bêtement dans la
finale quoi je sache jouer des coups
c'est simple en plus à chaque fois c'est
des gros regret quoi et ça m'est arrivé
plusieurs fois donc c'est une tendance
et du coup c'est du travail mais aussi
la pratique c'est les deux et du cou
pour way pour progresser au delà de
travailler faut beaucoup joué sans le
sait et ça c'est pas évident
moi j'avais joué j'ai pas mal joué deux
parties contre et mba qu un qui enfin on
s'est joint rapide a beaucoup de fois en
fait bon il est il habite dans le var un
émoi dans le 06 donc c'est vrai que dès
qu'il ya un tournoi
rapide on se voyait et bon j'ai tout le
temps perdu j'ai pas réussi à tenir une
fois la nuit on sait que quatre ou cinq
fois je crois et et genre peut-être deux
ou trois fois on a une position qui
était à peu près 20 kg était égal voire
un final égal 1 elle a en fait le
problème c'est que on n'a pas la même
technique et que moi je perds beaucoup
de temps à trouver les bons coups il a
cherché et au final en fait ben lui les
trouve tempo moi je prend plus de temps
et d'extinction après c'est fini et
c'est vrai que c'est moi j'adore je vais
contrôler
et apprend quoi ces coups là non mais
ils ont une tagline de folie et du coup
ils sont stables même quand c'est pas
hyper bien passé pour eux barre à
l'imposition égal ils vont encore jouer
quoi donc
c'est ça en fait il a joué puis
bon après les parties contre lui en
défense et en plus nommées soient soyez
hauts des bas
c'est ça ouais ils vont rester avec avec
des changes c'est hyper frustrant en
route tout à fait
c'est ce qui fait qu'ils sont hyper fort
en fait ils minimisent les moments quand
ils sont mal ils arrivent à vous
accrocher ce battre jusqu'au bout et
vous quand vous accrocher contre ces
joueurs là que vous avez fait une énorme
partie bas ils vous font des coups bien
moi est oui darko tu as vu tout de suite
que cet objet si ce n'est pas un coup
jouable à cause de tout reprendre et 3
pas de ce pas de souci
ça fait comme toi kevin est en tout cas
demain tu vas jouer un jour à 2100 2002
thain finale et qui vivrait kippa nul de
ce qui égale à la différence entre nul
est égal c'est que et gagne encore des
choses à faire et que nul tu vas pas me
la jouer tant il a joué par essayer de
faire ce qu'on peut faire
sauf que sauf que j'ai déjà remarqué
justement par manque de technique même
quand je poussais des fois des mecs je
pouvais aussi me prendre les pieds dans
le tapis ce qui n'arrive pas non plus
donc tu vois il ya plusieurs choses
dedans c'est dans ces histoires 1 mais
la technique c'est très important elle
s'acquiert aussi donc pas le travail
mais aussi par par l'expérience et
et du coup comme on le disait hier on
voit que tous les joueurs tous les hyper
talent qu'ils sont en présence là dans
ce tournoi du tata steel ben au delà de
beaucoup travaillé ils sont tout le
temps tournoi il ya quelqu'un dans le
chat qui se posaient la question par
rapport après une annonce da
qui est tout petit comme ça ni à la
sarine on m'a déjà posé la question et
et il ya le côté travail
dans certaines nations ou pour le se
pose la question du bien-être de
l'enfant c'est une bonne question et
j'avais vu que c'était du rhin ce que
s'infligent et les jeunes hier matin tu
en parles s ouvre toi tu as été sur
place il me semble
que sur le site de l'école de prenda à
l'époque c'était en conseil trois heures
des chèques par jour et six heures le
week-end mais il faudrait que toi qui a
été en habituant c'est peut-être plus se
trouve là dessus
des enfants à l'école
mais après je sais pas combien de
combien de temps grand par jour ils
consacrent français dépend de chaque
enfant mais c'est vrai que c'est un
travail phénoménal
ce qui est important aussi de voir
choses et quand j'ai dû aller c'était le
cas en fait c'est les enfants eux mêmes
qui décident de vraiment faire ça elle
travaille énormément c'est pas les
parents qui sont derrière lui il y en a
qui bossent post boss boss cinéma qui
ont demandé quel gamin il sait qu'il va
unir fois
et donc c'est vraiment différent par
rapport à nous en france où nous bien il
faut vraiment être derrière les enfants
pour les pousser à travailler
sans nous ils travaillent pas en france
tout à fait en règle générale il ya une
minorité quand même c'est souvent les
meilleurs d'ailleurs les hyper talent
qui arrivent à se discipliner le même
mais mais en main de ce qui se passe
c'est que c'est eux qui les enfants eux
mêmes qu'ils savent qu'il faut le faire
et que et ils sont ils pas disciplinés
et puis à prague culturellement situ
il ya une logique métier derrière quoi
souffre donc c'est vrai que pour
certains jeunes français c'est difficile
de voir l'intérêt de
bosser à fond les et chats qui voient ça
comme un passe-temps accéder à et des
fois t'es pris dans le truc tu es bon en
fait et du coup tu dois commencer à
bosser dur parce que tu es très vite
considéré comme un adulte en termes de
niveaux et la charge de travail
aujourd'hui à cause des ordinateurs et
monstrueuse et c'est vrai que c'est
quand même plus facile
de tasses train à cette charge de
travail cité dans une logique métier
derrière en france même un hyper talent
en tant qu'entraîneur j'aurais pas le
réflexe de dire ben vas-y tu vas faire
pro etc je vais expliquer si tu veux
devenir au moins mettre fi de mettre un
ancien grand maître international il vas
voir tu t'y met je donne tout le
discours mais ça va être à lui de
s'autodiscipliner sachant que
le fait de devenir pro échec est
quasiment impossible parce qu'on parle
plus d'être grand maître on parle d'être
gros mètres à 2600 et grand maître à
2600 il vivra très mal
des échecs ou alors comme beaucoup de
force joueur français actuellement qui
sont à ce niveau là il faut commencer à
donner des cours faire des commentaires
etc etc mais vivent que des échecs en
tant que joueur bah c'est une bonne idée
d'être au moins de 1650 est en fait
comme on sait que notre niveau va pas
croître avec l'âge ça c'est une règle de
base et il vaut mieux est de 1700 voire
de 1750 et là on parle des 100 premiers
joueurs mondiaux voire même si on est à
2750 c'est plutôt les 50 voire 40
meilleurs joueurs mondiaux
donc c'est très très difficile voilà
donc tour b 3 vient d'être joué par sam
shankland bas c'est logique il défend
son fouet il veut faire le coup de barre
cola d'am-dam g6 et matériau gainant de
votre ami pat 19,7 connais très bien
c'est un petit cannois dont les deals
bonjour donc ça lui louis salut à toi
donc elle est il a une très bonne bande
très sympa en tout cas
avec pour premier set dans la ligne de
danton carsen donc à l'appel de 13,6
il voulait envoyer du lourd c'était
avant tours b 3 je traduirai il voulait
faire tout reprendre tour promet ça
c'est malin parce que il se dit bassil
vas-y prends mon fou et comme ça je te
maths alors si kung fu iliad 1.27 maths
et si
tu prends ma tour je veux faire le coup
de darko dame g6 alors il essaie de
bouger des pièces pour qu'on boit de
plus claire tout reprend bessette donc
tout reprendre et cela nous remettrons
des viles attaques du sur le fou détroit
pour faire dame g6 way et merci
maintenant hct du coup là j'ai pas le
choix je dois faire quoi j'ai eu
d'autres
hélas ici écrit défaire damas damas est
vraiment forcer la lune a non j'ai dit
une bêtise entame à 7,3 cette dame
justice d'alger 6 et là je repars à la
kasbah parce que si je vais en recettes
ça craint maintenant
ça
[Musique]
oui
il ya déjà ben ouais on sentit 2004 dont
condé d'un premier set bon déjà déjà ya
ça y est ça qui va être pénible on voit
que c'est pas logique par contre je peux
retourner en g8
on voit que ça va être ça va être nul
mais une promotion rigolote ce tour
premier set alors est ce qu on avait
mieux visiblement oui parce qu'on a vu
la jauge qui s'excitent est sûre surtout
retrouver
7,7 fou des sites intermédiaires s'il y
aurait tout reprendre et 7
mais
[Musique]
bon on punit ça
un poème de goethe entend regarder c'est
bien sauf tourcoing f2 pourquoi f2 13 en
un sens
c'était pas si simple
ouais c'est ce que je regardais il ya
quelque chose comme ça et là commencé
voici toujours pas claires en fait
qu'est-ce qu'on va
toujours ta ta dam en terre donc je peux
jouer soit ça non allez vous défendre
à chaque achat coup il ya une bêtise en
plus ça qu'est bon
c'est dur c'est dur la position et
espère du recyclage pour eve 2 mais bon
fallait jouer tous rêvent de là au lieu
de trois chars mais bon heureusement
qu'on a droit de bouger pièces en
souffre alors qu'est-ce qu'on rate
surtout reprend bessat puisqu'on a
trouvé nulle maintenant faut gagner tu
en prends mes sept îles et journaux
n'ont pas joué c'est qu'il ya une raison
qu'un
tour premier set alors c'est quoi
l'astuce je suis toujours une idée idée
marrante
j'ai trouvé fèves de
hockey tous rêvent 2
way c'est peut-être pas besoin d'une
histoire à
tour et je voulais faire tour bessette
est tombé un ok maintenant je sais pas
s'il faut pas faire
l'incident jesse j'ai tourbe et un
matin j'ai signé je vous le pouvoir
d'alger six tours bien et elle est
surtout bien sûr fou prend il ya deux
dames d un échec la tour soit devant et
on mange en f1 mais si fou f1 et bien je
peux faire la même chose avec tourcoing
f1 ça qui est beau aussi elle se
retrouve mes seins
sont là des gens on serait content
puisque appris de menaces au final mais
on peut quand même axa surtout des dames
des quatre et je hais je viens
rev 2 c'était c'est l'action crée ton
premier set c'était dur avant tout rêve
ou deux tours mais cette
laitue à ses membres les joueurs ils
vont quartier dû à une vitesse
tu vois
moi je encore tous réfutent à regarder
dame prend comme d'alger sila on adams
et 5 sans doute
qui doit régler les comptes du roi blanc
roi f1
mois et maintenant il n'y a plus trop de
menaces quand même côté côté des blancs
on peut se tirer
ok on vous et c'est très compliqué donc
belle proposition en tout cas
joly
c'est un c'est un jeune du top jeunes
oui
bah oui je vois bien
en chaîne qui nous a fait mal quand j'ai
accompagné cette année l'équipe de
marseille voilà il s'est vengé d'une
partie du franc jeunes est proprement
des coûts
voilà
et du coup ils ont des belles idées les
petits jeunes dans le tchat bravo louis
c'était une jolie variantes
donc du coup ça a été beaucoup plus
calme chez anciens que sont champions de
carlson message ou quand même pas mal
parce qu'on en tire donc tourbe et trois
menaces dame g6 et étonnamment magnus a
vu la menace ont un coût et il a joué
tous rêvent 6 et du coup ça me chante on
doit jouer un coup prophylactique avec
avec h3 pour limiter les idées
à terme de matières gloire on a vu
qu'elle aime pas le problème avec ma du
couloir avant de tomber cette notamment
donc h3d la sarre avec ces problèmes là
mais c'est encore une partie
parties jouables par kevin a beaucoup
avant conséquences qu'on se passer une
petite page de pub comme d'habitude
je voulais te relever ce qui s'est passé
totalement à votre chat ou il ya
plusieurs de nos erreurs je crois sont
en train d'essayer d'organiser un match
toi contre moi en blitz
ah bah ça
arrivera forcément stouff ça arrivera
forcément
tous et un briscard moi ça va pas
marrant j'ai changé je sens que j'ai
tilté texte ou femme choc il est et il
est plein de fourberie stouff chant bien
moi c'est plutôt les échecs stable ça il
me fallait me le proposait il ya 15 ans
souffre dans la jeunesse
d'autant plus qu'on a une partie longue
en 2009 et tout m'avait battu en plus
j'avais 300 points et l'autre plus que
lui à ce moment là voilà ça le souvenir
ce to face ce moment
c'était c'était pas mon tournoi on sait
on a déjà parlé mais oui oui c'est une
belle idée c'est une belle idée faire
faire un petit match tous les deux ça ça
promet
d'ailleurs pour ceux qui voudraient
qu'ils voudraient aller voir cette belle
partie elle est sur cette base
[Rires]
à la revanche
l'immortel de stéphanie l'appeler
l'immortel
il a imprimé puis l'a encadré quoi ça me
fait vraiment mal ça me fait vraiment
mal voilà en tout cas n'hésitez pas si
vous l'avez voir avoir à les voir nos
chaînes respectives et et on organisera
ce petit match que tout le monde veut
voir vous inquiétez pas c'est le genre
de truc qui nous fait bien rigoler même
si on sait tous les deux qu'il y aura
une énorme pression dans ce cas là et
qu'il faut le gagner ce match-là parce
qu'après on sait bien que il y aura des
petites et petites railleries comme on
sait faire des petits tacles pas
forcément glisser les deux pieds
décollés mais il y aura des petits tas
comme un dock en tout bien tout honneur
par exemple m m je sais pas
par exemple
c'est ça la totale en plus tu vois voilà
ça va la totale mais on aime bien
on aime bien qu'on aime bien ce genre de
choses je crois qu'il faut qu'on fasse
la petite la petite pub souffre
s'est imposée par tous comme
twitch donc chaque heure
bon ben ok bon vous retrouve tout de
suite les gens et on voit le dénouement
la de cette journée pour l'un soyez deux
petites nul mais là il va y avoir des
résultats décisifs assurément donc on
revient tout de suite après la petite
page de pub et à vous dis à tout de
suite des amis
[Musique]
on
en
[Musique]
pomme
à
on
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on est reparti on était en train de
discuter puisque couvy joy dans le chat
nous amis que prague nanda était en
train de s'en sortir il m'a fait il m'a
fait croire et du coup je suis
directement allé voir la position j'ai
fait la petite blague à stéphanois où il
ya près d'un ans d'acquis en train de
s'en sortir sauf que bah il avait déjà
été regardée lui-même et
apparemment kovic
m'hamed il n'a pas l'air d'accord avec
toi je peux te dire que ils se demandent
même peut-être un peu pourquoi son
adversaire en train de continuer cela
parce qu'une fois que le pion f3 tout va
sauter mais il ya vraiment plus d'espoir
quoi la f3c l'espoir et on regarde
qu'eux on voit que mamediarov est en
train de regarder dans le décor de la
salle
et là c'est extrêmement dur pour le pour
le petit le peu de signes à prague d'un
mandat rappelons qu'il a déjà été
champion du monde de sa catégorie d'âge
et là c'est l'heure de la récolte pour
m'hamed
qui n'est vraiment pas inquiet voilà il
va il va tranquillement gagné maintenant
cette position est rien à dire gros
pions de plus pour mamediarov la tour
très active une des faiblesses de pions
passer ça va gagner donc on voit pas on
va pas s'attarder trop de sur cette
partie
et si penco guy pour aller voir un petit
peu comment tourner cette finale et vous
voyez on se rappelle un moment où les
pions étaient sur leur case de départ
bas à ça y est les trois pions passé
sont en train de se mettre en place et
surtout le cavalier h2 bas il est
vraiment pas beau donc du coup
du coup c'est un petit peu un petit peu
embêtant
et là bas on remarque aussi que ici
penco et il a plus beaucoup de temps
il a trois minutes je pense qu'ils me
manquent franchement la partie de
diriger adoré aujourd'hui un grosse
prépa position obtenu atypique et du
coup maintenant on
on voit que c'était pas si facile en
pratique a
gagné c'est pas encore gagné mais en
train de prendre une option
puisque là c'est cette chanson entre
sont en marche vers la victoire
alors après
ça c'est sûr mais il est encore
difficile de gagner cette position
stouff un papa si facile
est-ce que tu as un petit plan de gains
là pour faire parler de la technique
parce que c'est une technique bizarre
lahens et c'est atypique quand même déjà
rage est 5ème avec deux montées droit
pour monter les pions endroit g5
pourrait menacer h
& m f3 bon j'ai trois giratoires
cavalière trois échecs mais en tout cas
ils fois il faut aussi des petits fous
ces droits donc j'ai pensé algérois g5
pas forçant bourgeois h4 tout de suite
mais aussi pour échanger de jouer f5 f5
ça va être dur à jouer pour l'instant
parce que ben
ces personnes qui croyaient pts 5 mais
en maintenant une tour en cinq gp menacé
f5 le problème c'est que si j'ajoute
heureux cinq ira 3.96 donc bon ça va
paraître long mais si je faisais trois
et cinq tours j'ai 6 puis tours 5 tel
que je pourrais passer le pion m mais
bon une fois que charef 5 après je peux
plus elle arrive quatre non plus donc
c'est vraiment très très lent
peut-être simplement qu'il croît de 5 à
6 4 parce que déjà il y aura toujours
les menaces de g3 ou h300 qu'on le joue
vraiment mais on a tout moment on menace
de le jouer et c'est dur de co pour pour
les blancs
non en fait ça
va venir cette position
active les pièces ça prend l'espace ou
normales et formelles
j'ai bien aimé d'arc francky dire ça
mérite un ban de couv itx qu'il a dit
non non c'était une bonne blague et roy
g5 confirmé
aguerris joue le coup de stouff
et salue alliotte on va métrage 4 après
salut à tous ceux qui nous rejoignent
elliott qui aurait pu me suis peiné
pièce les vieux après en fait on fait
une partie
s'appelle une partie en différé ont
différé avec alliotte il est
républicaine qui est ce qu'il ya
quelques coups j'ai joué à tout impôt en
me levant le matin
et j'aurais pu me faire piquer pièce
millions de l'anah les donc j'étais bien
content
c'est comme en ski promologis c'est tout
le tour j'ai six aussi pour laisser
cette tour la libre
tient plus d'avenir
non me faire les deux déjà et voir après
parce qu'en fait si vous voulez avec guy
on aseptise est là pour avancer et avec
les blancs je sais pas quoi faire et là
c'est l'horreur si vous n'avez pas
d'objectif dans une position petit à
petit ça va complètement déconner on
sait donc
c'est une belle galère en perspective
elliott il digère atteint maintenant
c'est une pièce non
pièce oui c'est bien ce que tu dis
jj c'est tout je pense que tu es pas
obligé effectivement le problème de
tours g6 il se dit bon je vais peut-être
me faire enfoncer de l'autre côté donc
du coup tu gardes à tours angers 7 pour
le moment tu améliores omac genre h4
déjà
sur à ce cas tu auras des questions
c'est peut-être choix obligé jouer
cavalier f1 le le choix régler les
blancs
et alors ce sera peut-être le moment de
jouer un coup comme un tour g6 ou g3
parce que la tour ouais j'ai trois ça
deviendra très intéressant donc on va
voir un petit peu mais je pense qu'il va
être dans cette config après guiry
et ça sera très compliqué faut juste
vérifier qu'ils aient pas cavalier
projet kde mais je pense pas
mais non il n'y aura pas donc du coup du
coup ça promet d'être dure
alors que chez jean-claude carle scène
juste pour vous dire on peut déjà vous
annoncer que c'est presque nulle
maintenant puisque les deux joueurs ont
échangé les dames peux vous montrer
comment s'est passé on a fait une belle
variantes de louis tout à l'heure qui
nous disait qu'il y avait de la tactique
mais maintenant il y en a plus du tout
donc un an ses nerfs entre avec ses
pièces en d2 ce qui a conduit un c'était
oublier une vraie ouais c'était une
vraie volonté de champions dans info de
se prendre tour d2 et carlson en a eu
marre de cette position visiblement
à accepter et à jouer d'amd ci s'est pas
pris la tête je pensais que en fait je
pensais que l'idée des blancs c'était de
reprendre plus tôt de l'adami si un se
trouve pour être tout à fait ok et sur
fou prend on voit que la jauge me dit
qu'il y avait il y avait mieux que d'amd
je vois pas trop quel est le coût qui
pointent f2 ouais mais bon après tout
reprend j'ai rien vu
puisque bien sûr sur des cartons fait
fouet fin
non il n'y a pas je crois pas
ou alors on joue
autour des 6 sangliers tour des deux
chais pas
dans des cas comme des cadres pour le
pressing
c'est un peu étonnant ça ressemble pas
car en scène dans cette position de
devoir abdiquer sera un grand mot mais
de pas avoir cherché plus que
dam des six dans cette position
c'est quoi le portugal si on regarde
juste
pour répondre à bas le drian d'avinel
dans la partie guy en fait aux cavaliers
f3 pour sacrifier le cavalier mais le
problème c'est que derrière je regrette
de tout le monde donc
ça ne marchera pas là dans la partie ii
guéri il ya quand même
trois pions pour une pièce donc s'il en
maintenant un seul pion ça va pas quoi
vous voyez cavaliers f1 je craque donc
en fait peut-être que l'idée proposée
trouve c'était genre cavaliers j'ai
enfin laisser ferrache 4k lg cat et
prend 9 6 pour qu'il y ait deux pions
mais c'est un pelage aussi hein parce
que ça les fait un nouveau pion enfants
alors que fais tu là on est quand même
au niveau du matériel on est à égalité
1-1 pions savoir un point j'en ai trois
donc j'ai trois points et un carré ça
vaut trois points est bon par rapport
aux options plus et on s'avance et plus
sont dangereux
donc en année on peut échanger de sa
rivale cavalli quand on pense que ça
devient
dangereux mais pour l'instant bon les
plombs je n'avance pas encore
h 3 c'est pas vraiment une menace pour
l'instant parce que j'aurai rouages de
et je pourrai un blocus et cnooc à
valleraugue et 3
situés g3 et si la casa 3 donc je pense
pas que pour l'instant il est d'urgence
de vraiment s'inquiéter vallier reste
encore des choses à faire
j'ai quand même cave et les plus vains
sur l'échiquier donc un jour peut-être
que ça va se terminer comme ça on va y
avoir un accès des camions des pions et
puis inutile à ce qui va se faire c'est
mon possible mais pour l'instant c'est
un peu trop tour
de faire ça quand on voit que
il ya parents de menaces chez narquois
du coup tu vois ici pas contenir ou pas
souffre
oui
là tu me chauffe lasse tout fan est en
train de m'échauffer chanterai pas ce
que
moi
franchement je trouve vraiment que la
position noir est plus facile à jouer et
moi je dirais bien victoire guèye
gérait bien victorieux tu veux qu'on en
fait pour tester ce tout vous voyez
comment jeu comment j'ai fait c'est une
petite fourberie de ma part mais je lui
ai fait comprendre que j'étais d'accord
mais en fait ça m'a fait rigoler que ça
vienne pas de moi que ça vienne d'eux
souffre il n'a pas pu s'empêcher tout
dit est ce que tu veux bien sûr bien sûr
bien sûr ça va intéresser un petit peu
cette finale on va relancer un petit peu
et du coup oui bien sûr je veux parce
que en pratique en tout cas je sais
qu'avec les blancs
je nagerai pas cette finale l'a donc du
coup
mais je me dis que si génial si j'ai pas
compris japon quelque chose et je perds
un seul un symbole un coup j'ai pris la
master class des cyclones qu est ce qui
plaît et qu il s'est quand même sorti il
s'est quand même sortie de pas mal de
parties compliqué difficile notamment
contre ice bar c'était prévu donc bon
confiance mais la partie guéri je trouve
qu'il a vraiment trop bien joué et là et
aujourd'hui mérite quelque chose il
s'est bien préparé il a tout montré
depuis le début elle est très
pédagogique cette partie puisqu'il avait
les trois pions qui était ostéo départ
et il a réussi en travaillant à tout a
mené et on voit que son adversaire
recroquevillé et
je vois que le temps des six pinkos et
0,6 s'il est tombé autant c'est parfait
c'est le seul le plus facilement gagné
au monde
[Rires]
en tout cas s'il tient je perdrais le
som avec plaisir enfin je te dis ça
maintenant parce qu'il sait il n'a pas
encore tenu mais ouais j'aimerais bien
j'aimerais bien voir en tout cas
j'espère qu'ils vont pas s'accorder sur
une nulle un peu bidon je veux voir du
travail dans ce cas là c'est énorme
comme avec 4 c'est vrai que là tout à
l'heure c'était pas loin mais
mais comment dirais-je sur
sur celle là le chemin qu il n'a pas
l'air d'être qu'on le voit la cam là on
se dit pas qui va il va faire nul au
prochain coup quoi franchement un qui va
décider ce truc ouais très clairement
ça on l'avait dit voilà ils sont
accordés magnus a proposé les changes
après des dames détour oui on peut vous
dire tout à l'heure on a vu la jeune
tchèque site et
donc du coup j'étais regarder pourquoi
là je la joue sexy tu es ce que c'était
pas facile à titre perso de voir
pourquoi et apparemment le coup
préconisé c'était d'amd 5 juste pour
attaquer à 2
voilà pourquoi la juge s'est excité et
avec une idée assez simple qui était de
piquet le pion à da par mois n'était pas
facile à défendre puisque sur acat les
noirs pouvaient continuer par dame b 3
et quand vient le clouage du food et 3
mai aps été très difficile à aa défendre
et c'est typiquement
un peu étonnant pour manu ce qu'ils
voient quasiment tous un qu'il ait pas
de vue ou est senti le coup pour
continuer cette partie elle a peut-être
vu et il ya quelque chose qui la
dérangeait mais on peut se demander quoi
parce que c'est vrai qu'à y réfléchir
dans cette position on sentait que les
noirs étaient peut être un chouia mieux
du fait du petit pressing qu'ils
exercent sur le pion à f2 quoique les
quinze manches sont ouvertes mais la
sève bien empêchait les créations de
batteries donc là c'est vrai que il y
avait un plan tout simple qui est tapé
le plus isolé c'est pas très dur pour
lui vu son niveau et c'est vrai que
c'était pas facile s'il pose la question
de réagir en fait ça aurait pu coûter du
temps cette position h en clans dans
fait
et ne sera jamais n'a pas joué non
c'était
mais ce n'est pas si facile c'est vrai
allez je pense que vous êtes vous êtes
d'accord il ya peut-être moyen de mettre
un peu de pression après c'est parce que
pour tout vous dire c'est parce que la
jauge a indiqué un gag la partie est
finie que je suis allé voir ce qui ce
qui était possible de faire et du coup
on voulait pas proposer un camp nou on
était sur des dames des cats et cetera
il fallait juste aller taper le petit
pion à 2 mais pour un joueur comme
magnus c'est vraiment pas passé
difficile donc pour le petit point là
zain ont tous passé une autre victoire
prochaine de m'améliorer dans cette
finale de deux cavaliers 1 puisque là il
ya déjà presque presque des cinq qui va
gagner
le cip écologie ryoma ça va être très
intéressant ça sent la partie fil rouge
c'est la partie qui me va nous amener
jusqu'au bout de la nuit
et
vidic grande delius vie dit grand des
lieux ça fait un moment qu'on n'est pas
allé les voir je pense c'est l'autre
partie à suivre celle là parce que les
autres vont se terminer je pense pas le
mandat du mans ça va bouger beaucoup
donc je pense que c'est la partie roman
regarde et on va aller voir directement
le vide avec un réseau de maths bon pas
encore
5 des choses qui peuvent arriver la
paire de foot blanche qui va poser
problème les gains prime sur le plan des
je donne pas très cher de l'aveu de la
peau de des grands des lieux saints il
reste neuf matches à jouer on
s'était arrêté vous rappeler après royal
7 gpra f5 et là on disait que c'était
extrêmement dur de tenir cette position
ce qu'on n'avait plus trop d'idées voilà
et
bah ça a été ça s'est avéré vrai si vous
voulez puisque ils ont beaucoup de mal
avec le jeu de pièces les noirs et les
blancs ils ont amélioré tranquillement
leur position ils sont patients
il tourne autour de sa proie il ya
vraiment grosse qualité de jeu est là il
a tout ouvert avec ses cadres parce
qu'un jour faut faire parler la paire de
faux
noms grosse grosse partie encore de
visiter et salaires dur pour grand des
lieux saints pour pour popopopop
problème
le roi est faible le cavalier en 8 ne
joue pas et il ya un grosse pression sur
des gonades blanche agen a eu et il a
une minute s'il a la tête dans le sac
dans ce tournoi parce que
il a du mal à
à mettre les points
on est très très dur
il a joué cavalier g7
mais là
je dois pouvoir déjà gagné en force tout
fin
avec des cahiers français 6 puis on
prendrait 5 ou faut prendre 5 intercalé
d'abord maintenant il est quasiment
si je prends ces six pions point que je
prends des cinq pages et bien j'ai pris
un pion déjà
gagné en
moins il y avait les premiers champions
quand tu veux manger f5 revanche 16,6
non tu peux pas en plus parce qu'il faut
prend 1,5
que manger des deux prises et manger
parce que c'est ça que tu regardes ça
ouais ouais
ça mais mais de toute façon je crois que
well et noir sont justes foutu il ya
plusieurs gars en plus dans cette
position les quais procès 6 a été joué
et là c'est même confiant mais prend et
prises des 5 il se prend pas la tête il
se demande un petit peu
nos menaces prises ces six
années il va jouer ces cinq là au
printemps mais là c'est on à la paire de
fou contre nous on a tous qui va mal
victoire prochaine de visite on peut
juste jeter un coup d'oeil à marcory m'a
dit ça fait un moment qu'on n'a pas été
le voir toof ça se passe mal a
alors ça a été une partie on a ça fait
un moment qu'on n'a pas été d'avoir
cette partie alors
il y avait l'air d'avoir un gros
avantage pour marc-andré un moment en
tout cas
annoncé l'invs rc son adversaire à
régler blanc qui ici a peut-être raté
raté un gain
puisque après tout reprend 1,3 cm marc
andré qui était qui était vraiment bien
alors qu'est-ce qu'il a raté ça devait
pas être si facile parce que
on ne voit pas au premier coup d'oeil ce
que c'est ce qu'est processus qui devait
jouer mais ça paraît
pas si évident
peut-être qu'elle prend ses six avec non
il ya toujours des meurins
voit le gain blanc ici stouff je fais se
trouvait non je le connais tout à
l'heure j'ai vu la politique apte à
regarder le mieux j'ai vu qu'il y avait
déjà trois salles et pas à la place il
fait les dames à 4
alors dit nous maintenant que tu sais tu
vois
je partage avec toi mais
donc ça devait être dur c'est pour ça
que j'ai eu raison de de refiler le bébé
c'était pas si facile la veste de match
pour empêcher qu
est-ce que c'est dur on est d'accord
donc enfin devant ces complications
importantes pas trouvé par l'adversaire
ah oui là en fait
f3 donc là une qualité de moi il joue
tout sur le
sur le fait peut-être de jouer pour
[ __ ] un f5 mais moi ils sont nés y
avoir calé des six peut-être mais il ya
peut-être des ouais il ya des sacrifices
angers 6 donc il a pris peur marc andré
maury n'zi il a joué dame c3 pour calmer
ouais c'est ça il y avait des problèmes
un peu partout peut-être et du coup il a
voulu calmer la pause une dame c3 pour
échanger les dames
il a réussi son roulé il n'a pas échangé
les passer par damas mais la rendent une
pièce pour pour calmer le jeu quoi bon
la position les joueurs des deux côtés
un
nom se pose la question d'un défaut de
est ce qu'il faudrait changer d'âme fo 2
ce n'est pas la position de mahler
manière
intéressante quand même encore pour les
deux joueurs
c'est pour ça qu'il n'y a rien de fait
fo doit guider fougea câbles mais
peut-être food à chaque
arrêt mais je préférais je prends parce
que sinon j'ai peur de me prendre des
trucs comme ça enfin bon après avoir
c'est compliqué pour les
quatre 4 minutes contre 3 minutes alors
juste si on repart sur
victoires/défaites s'éprend des cinq
tours j'ai des 8es pressée 6 brèche la
traque âge complet abandon de la demande
des lieux ouais donc on va peut-être
rester
il est si pingre au jury mais il n'y a
pas de zai note mamediarov rail canada
s'était terminée du coup je préfère
rester sur la partie d'un cran marquant
dream aurait dit c'est on n'a pas trop
vu
ouais ça va être fini effectivement et
ils viennent de passer 40e ouais c'est
ça en fait c'est plus à cause de cela
que ça m'intéresse
de voir marc andrieu qui est en deuil
note donc il leur reste deux minutes
contre 4 ils ont quatre coups sûrs
chacun
quatre jours avant le 40e coup je vous
rappelle la cadence 1h 1h 40
pour 40 coup ça s'arrangerait plus quand
minutes pour 20 coups et un quart
d'heure pour la fin de la partie
parcours du début à la fin c'est une
cadence
du coup très lente mais on voit que les
partis sont pas
sont pas si lente elles sont assez
rapides sont finies assez rapidement
elle est partie et ça nous permet de
faire un petit point sur le challenger
donc pour l'instant marc andry
malheureusement ferme la marche mais il
ya eric à esi lui qui marche sur l'eau
le joueur indien puisque il a il a déjà
sept points il a déjà gagné aujourd'hui
donc sept points dans un tournoi de
cette qualité là c'est quand même très
très fort
vous de fou mairie gaz
irritant départ mais l'avez vu ben déjà
il a fait pas mal de public ça vexe
essbase india dernièrement et y gagner à
peu près 100 points d'un tournoi
en blitz
ils arrivent à se reprocher pas du monde
il avait 27 65 je prends en lots blitz
est d'ailleurs en chopper du monde de
blitz il était deuxième du tournoi à
trois rondes de la fin je crois et il a
fini par zéro pour toi un truc comme ça
ouais ce qui fait qu'on n'a pas trop vu
mais en fait il est très dangereux mais
ils étaient là tout le temps et là on
voit le temps qu'il a fait moi je les ai
vus je les ai vus la fête deux tournois
au portugal c'est donc moi je vais jouer
à 1 et le premier a fait 8 sur 9 oui
moyenne des lots à moyen et l'oat
ouais 2004 50 2005 facile sur abuser et
le deuxième il ay là il a raté un peu
mais il à
mai mais juste il est très très
impressionnés ghazi et moi je le vois
vraiment arriver à 2007 franchement dans
les mois qui arrivent
houeillès j c'est tout c'est bien le
coup qui a été jouée fou prend b5 avec
des idées de dams et 7 en cas de reprise
mais c'était pas évident calculé parce
qu'il ya des dames prend 3 aussi
pour essayer d'aller chercher le roi
blanc aussi avec l'idée d'un emprunt f4
et que le roi est un petit peu faible
c'est encore très compliqué cette
position
et j'aime bien tout dans l'esprit des
deux joueurs jouent bien quoi et ça
c'est beau ça serait un peu moins parce
que j'ai l'impression que
la partie était plutôt en faveur de de
marc andré est là la position
c'est une position hyper complexe et pas
si facile que ça semble-t-il pour les
noirs alors là je vous indique que c'est
égal donc d'emprunt 3 c'est évidemment
le coup c'est normal et après fou prend
ses six têtes d'un point f4 ouais c'est
ça
et au final le cavalier tient tout tient
la case f3 qu'un contenant le puits auca
doit tomber
et la tournée pas encore actives n'en
faut faire garder cette position je
pense que c'est un peu plus facile à
jouer
à peut-être quand même ses fans qu'il y
à
vraiment j'ai du mal d'un preuve quatre
fous prendrait 5 hors effets 6,2 me deux
nouvelles mais tous réussis je peux
aussi jouer dames c'est cette
faudra vérifier quand même dame c'est
cette
honte là ça fait hyper d'affaires si tu
vas y
je veux pas de quoi trop non plus avec
avec madame voyez ces histoires la déco
ça fait super peur et il reste deux
minutes et la marque comment il a une
grosse décision à prendre
alors effectivement je vous indique que
c'est légal mais je préfère me mettre du
côté blanche mais peut-être qu'il faut
prendre des caps justement parce que se
défend dé 5,1 c'est
ce qu'il veut pas dire que je peux pas
le prendre quoi
vous l'avez si tu le prends mal géré le
coin maccioni le fort c'est non
ouais tu peux tu pourras pas je bourre
plus
basse que l'idée c'est quand je prends